[Music]
Running a Restaurant in Spain should be
a dream but for 26-year-old Lawrence
Davey it's a nightmare this ising
critical that's not good that's raw I'm
not going to taste that yet but it looks
burnt it's the worst meal we've ever had
he's in the [__] five PL here 1 2 3 4
five the first thing I've spotted is dog
[__] and if I can't put him back on his
feet he'll be on the next plane home
when's one of you going to step forward
with a pair of bollocks when are you
guys going to stop [__] around with
this excuses cuz that was [__]
[Music]
shocking cadel Soul Spain for the first
time I'm abroad on a special mission to
rescue a failing British run
restaurant during the summer months
thousands of Brits will invade the
Mediterranean Coastline and spend their
hard earned
cash and to cated for the masses more
and more British restaurants are opening
on the Costa Campion chips sausage and
chips fish and chips barbecue
chicken get it right here and you could
be sitting on a gold mine how many
portions of chips would you serve well
per week roughly we'd probably do in
excess of 100 portions a day so 7 800 a
week how are the chips very good yeah
what would you do if I band chips from
here I would not be too happy at all did
you not come no probably not no this is
English totally and it's good
English is there anything on the ca that
doesn't come with
chips one more steak garnish please and
a lamb shank I'll get
that one restaurant owner who thought he
spotted a gap in the market is
26-year-old Brit Lawrence
[Music]
Davy 18 months ago he B £40,000 from his
dad an open laara bana 500 M off the
beach in the coastal Resort of
n this restaurant has great potential to
be very successful and very popular um
it's in a great location but I've been
doing it for a year and a half now and I
haven't seen any success
whatsoever armed with his Cen degree and
a few years managing nightclubs and
restaurants Lawrence designed a
Mediterranean menu with a Twist to lure
the Brits away from the rean
chips my particular favorite King prawns
in garlic and ginger and chili served
with our signature chocolate sauce on
the side not very popular um which kind
of proves The Adventurous side of my
customers with the prawns in chocolate
sauce failing to win round the Brits he
lost 22 Grand in his first
year I don't know whether I went about
it the wrong way or whether people don't
want it or aren ready for it I don't
know since then he's broadened his menu
to a massive 72 dishes cooking
everything from Chinese chicken to
Turkish kebabs I've even served chicken
nuggets and chips to an adult and I
absolutely hate it I really hate
it but with Takens down on last year
he'll be lucky to survive the summer let
alone the
winter I'm in Spain to stop laara from
going
under hello Hi how are you Hi very well
how are you very well la yes it is good
to see you and you when did it start
going really quiet when did it um we
suddenly SN about September last year
suddenly just went you know the light as
if the light was switched off um and it
was just it just died um ever since then
we've been losing money what did you
know about restaurant before you opened
it um I said I did my degree did my
internship in America in terms of that's
training in terms of sure sure um it was
a nightclub in shelham and then became
restaurant manager of a big restaurant
in London and that's when i' like really
said you know I'm doing it I'm doing
really well I'm succeeding in every you
know what I'm doing why can't I do it
for myself they need it they need me in
nura they really need me to do great
stuff and now you're 26 Y and in the
[__] ship yeah how bad in the ship
I'm
€12,000 in debt 2,000 yeah so 70 grand
yeah so the new is really on your neck
I've either got to make it here or go
back to London and pay back to my father
[__] signature dishes or what would you
say signature dishes um we do a great
prawns dish with a chocolate sauce which
I've done from day one prawns with
chocolate sauce PRS with chocolate sauce
yeah so start and dessert at the same
time well F me that sounds
different right let's see what a former
nightclub manager has to offer the Brits
abroad huge menu extraordinary menu um
and then different themes flamco Burger
Knight Kat menu Chinese chicken or pork
confused to what the [__] going
on if I'd wanted a Chinese I would have
gone to one but I'm in Spain let's hope
Lawrence's signature dish of prawns in
chocolate sauce gives me the flavor of
the Med cool
deal I mean it's worse than a chocolate
sauce it's um hot overs spicy chili
chocolate Salt well that's
just stupid arrogance ready trying to
match something that's never going to
go if that's how Lawrence serves up
fresh local prawns then I wonder what
he's got in store for my fet steak Kebab
well he's gone for the Kebab which is
what wow factor dish when you know it
comes out on the hook so I think he gets
to see that bit of what we do [__] me is
that how they always serve oh
Jesus [__]
me it's the kind of thing you imagine
Jordan eating with her [__] hands
behind her back is someone taking the
piss how can you expect something like
that of that to be cooked at the same
time A Philip Stak
Kebab may not sound that exciting but it
should taste delicious and that in terms
of presentation looks like a p of
[__] if I thought my Kebab was
overcooked that's nothing compared to
what's happening to my creme
catalana all that smoke coming out of
the kitchen is okay there dessert from
my dessert it's just when they they burn
the top burn the top well not burn the
top that's they burn the kitchen
down [__] me well it's certainly burned
it looks like a [__] ice hockey puck
look at
it comes with an appointment at the
dentist tomorrow morning at 9:30 [__]
me it's liquid and it's it's ruined so
when you sat with all these fresh
ingredients on your doorstep and the
climate they've got the simpler it is
the better it's going to be
unfortunately they've got more
complicated and tried to be clever and
completely lost the [__]
PL the first rule for running a
restaurant in Spain is don't ruin good
produce with fancy gimmicks good food
will always sell itself Lawrence's
novelty dishes may have been designed to
turn heads but all it's done for me is
turn my
stomach prawns the flavor of the prawns
was extraordinary fresh vibrant why do
you want to [__] around and put
chocolate sauce on there um cuz I don't
want to be boring I want to be exciting
I thought it was [__] hideous didn't
work but then I came to this [__]
schlong that Kebab have you actually
ever sat at the table and watched six
customers with this [__] donkey's
dick swinging in front of their face
it's hilarious well that is that that is
is you know it's a talking point it's
it's a it's a wow factor that's a w
Factor yeah it's a fet steak Yeah it was
tough as old boots I don't know you know
let before you start [__] mouthing up
let me just show you a cube that big and
a cube that big I'm not going to cook
the same time that my fault oh [__] me
here we go can I just finish the
sentence first simbad and then you can
[__] come back on me in a minute that
out there was embarrassing so it's
painful if it's painful for me and
you're €2,000 [__] EUR in the [__]
[__] knows how you sleep at night I
don't you know I feel so [__] about the
whole thing but deep down I really want
it to work I want my dream to come true
you're in
Spain you don't have to be that [__]
quirky to be good I'll see you in the
morning I've certainly got my work cut
out I get the feeling nightclub boy
isn't going to give up his novelty
dishes without a fight prawns and
chocolate sauce
[Music]
for the first time I'm in Spain on a
mission to turn around a failing British
run
restaurant former Nightclub and
restaurant manager Lawrence Davy came to
Nar to conquer the Costa he thought his
novelty dishes of swinging kebabs and
prawns and chocolate sauce would win
over the egg and chips loving Brits but
the Brits aren't biting and after
sampling his food I can see why Lawrence
thought he was going to come over to
Spain and take it by storm he opened up
at 24 years of age using his dad's
[__] money he thought his balls were
bigger than the mountains and he thought
he was going to bring a Mediterranean
twist with a difference he's got all the
gimmicks and he thinks by being simple
it's too plain for Spain but you'd never
think he's
€12,000 in [__]
debt it's mid August
and N is flooded with British
tourists restaurants on the Costa will
make a quarter of the annual profit in
August
alone even leata will be busy and boor
do they need to be okay two chicken
sauté fre pitas morus one cocktail
tonight is my chance to see how leara
copes with a full service with Lawrence
cooking the alakat dishes alone in the
kitchen his suf Norm is grilling the
kebabs and steaks on the Terrace
barbecue
so this is your little dungeon then this
is your is this is where they lock me in
for the evening yeah Lawrence might not
have much experience as a chef but he
has been a restaurant
manager maybe his skilled lies in
employing the best staff to do the best
jobs this goes up and down so I can
higher or lower it according to cooking
temperatures [__] so it's a very
modern updated barbecue yes it's more
like a torture rack for food a torture
rack for food is not joking
[Music]
now in my book I think that's well done
now suffering on top of the grill are 10
Chicken Kebabs that have yet to be
ordered why did you why' you cook me so
early on I've only just done them
they're cooked yeah they're coming off
now they're not really barbecued are
they almost like poached well they're
poached on a barbecue when I sealed them
off poached them and then finished them
on the barbecue again kebabs grilled
poached and left sitting in the heat
they're hardly fresh off the
barbecue but according to Norm there's
plenty of life left in them yet I
usually use them tomorrow for one day I
say I will use them tomorrow they want
these when side are you out your [__]
mind I know I was letting myself go
there but I've told you the truth I
respect your honesty but do me a favor
yeah don't even serve those to the Stray
Cats after tonight let alone the [__]
customers thank
you [__]
hell rule number two for running a
restaurant in Spain tourists might have
holiday insurance but that doesn't mean
you can give them Spanish tummy when
cooking on a barbecue don't take
risks does he honestly serve the [__]
barbecue kebabs the following night
yes it's your business I know
and barbecues at the best of times are
not the things to be [__] played with in
a way that it's a
toy and why don't you stop him
serving I don't know Norm's Norm he's
he's in a world of
hisone and as night falls the world of
laara becomes even darker Norm looks
like he's preparing for a wake and after
seeing his kebabs I wouldn't be
surprised this we're at [__] midnight
mass here you know that I know I know I
know what's
that this is the Dynamo torch isn't it
right see what's going on here
eh cooking by Clockwork torch it doesn't
get any more Mickey Mouse than this you
need more light out here I do need more
light what's the cost of a light bulb
well done Philip sorry well done Philip
well done filler y we haven't got that
so you H
know I ordered a finish steak about an
hour ago and it hasn't turned up yet I'm
just I'm just bloodly starving
hungry the food may not be Spanish but
there's certainly something Manana about
manager Alex's service I've been sat
there over an hour for the main course
he's cooking it and the plates are in
there this fragmented [__] service is
horrendous you know
that is it normal for customers to wait
this long PR yeah I can't go any quicker
than I'm going I'm going as quickly as I
possibly can it's not as if I'm not
trying he can try as hard as he likes
but no Chef can cook 72 different dishes
on his own to keep up with his orders
Lawrence is throwing everything onto his
pler grill it doesn't get any lazier
than that he's depending on that pler
Grill to cook everything from [__]
dad to kebabs to chat Bond and then this
[__] lazy Med vge that is the most
disgusting way I've ever seen [__]
good ingredients bastardized he might as
well open a [__] greasy spoon and
serve vegan chips cuz that's that's
[__]
disgusting the huge menu the lazy
cooking and the customers waiting hours
for Food Lawrence has lost the plot I
don't think I've actually quite ever
been faced with something that already
so early on looks like such an uphill
struggle it's not a shame it's [__]
especially when you're charging money
for it that's not
cooking
it's day three and the hard work starts
here stinks if I'm to stand any chance
of getting the pter out of the [__] this
place needs a fresh
start Forks on the floor glass
everywhere cigarettes chips dog [__] Fu
me I've seen some unsavory things in my
time Alex 2 seconds but dog [__] in the
dying area is
unforgivable first thing I've spotted is
dog
[__] that's not good good enough are you
happy with that no I'm not happy that's
disgusting yeah that's the third time
I've seen
it rule number three Running a
Restaurant in Spain isn't a
holiday there's a laidback attitude the
fact that we in Spain say we can afford
to be semi casual because we're dealing
with tourists no are we [__] we're
running a restaurant and the discipline
here can be the same in Paris can be the
same in London could be anywhere and
thinking that it's good to work in a
dirty kitchen or a dirty restaurant with
dog [__] in forget it great manager Alex
might be Lawrence's best mate from
college but he's clearly left his
standards back in
Britain if dog [__] goes on notice then
it's no surprise the kitchen is dripping
in
grease your friers are used a lot yeah
yeah you put fresh oil in there all the
time well we change them yeah yeah of
course you do yeah how often uh once a
week the oil would last a lot longer if
you got rid of all this stuff here look
there you go that's what you're cooking
out of yeah every time you put them
fresh o in there is making [__] all
difference that's
sludge with the restaurant having a much
needed deep clean there's something else
I want to clear
up last February Lawrence put on a
Valentine's dinner for the local Donkey
Sanctuary charity 100 British expats
paid 30 ahead for a fundraising meal
Rumor Has It law made a complete ass
it how bad did it go I mean was it a it
was a complete [__] up it was absolute
disaster in what way U the food was
overcooked dry tasteless what was the
menu um we did the chicken liver parf
which wasn't made until the morning so I
had no time to sit a chicken dish
wrapped in Sano ham baked in the oven
the chicken was so dry it was like carbo
did he give it to him on the house no
you charged them yeah [__] hell no
wonder they haven't been back you don't
have to rule number for when you're
running a restaurant in Spain don't piss
off the
locals when the tourists have gone home
the local XS account for 80% of your
Takens in the winter months without them
a British restaurant in Spain can't
[Music]
survive I'm heading into hostile
territory to make peace with the
natives I'm off to the local Donkey
Sanctuary and hopefully after meeting
them want to see if there's any chance
they actually come back and get the
restant one more [__] chance gracias
all I know about donkeys is they're
stubborn this isn't going to be easy and
I'm fascinated to get to the bottom of
what actually happened on that
fundraising dinner in terms of big event
I mean not be fun it was a sort of meal
that you were all waiting the next day
to have a very nasty trip into the
toilet what was the menu the menu was
pate initially yeah um which was frozen
you needed a blow torch Frozen defrost
it on your plate on the plate Frozen
Frozen on the
main course was chicken stuffed with
banana supposed to be served with
asparagus yes banana and asparagus it
supposed to be his signature dish not
another one with a [__] Twist on
there this became cancerous isn't it
because it spread like wildfire across
the town oh yeah well it's a small quite
arrogant about the whole thing if he
thinks he can survive in a small town
like this with that attitude it's got
another thing coming have you been back
S no is it any small fraction of
possibility if you could just think
about it if I could convince you just to
put one foot in the door it'd be a big
[__] help you promise us we don't
have to eat chocolate covered
prawns charging a local charity for a
bad meal smacks of unbelievable
arrogance Lawrence might have come to
Spain to offer the Brits something
different but so far all he's given them
is pretentious novelty
food I'm going to give him a taste of
his own medicine have a
taste of that
smell first maybe a little
taste first up a chocolate and prawn
smoothie based on Lawrence's signature
dish what's that taste of Lawrence
chocolate yeah you smell chocolate be
and then it tastes like um cookies
cookies taste that one again no thanks I
think it's [__]
horrible
okay
um next a chicken and banana smoothie
based on the dish he served at the
Donkey Sanctuary dinner there's a
texture in there which it's quite
stringy stringy string it says stringy
texture it's a banana and string no man
banana and something horrible in it
again mine folds
off the first
one is [__] prawns and chocolate
could you taste the prawn
there um well I knew there was something
in there that was not very nice you
didn't get it what I'm trying to say if
you got the best of of prawns let them
[__] Taste of prawn don't let them
taste of prawn and
chocolate this is the most painful
smoothie cuz it's the chicken and banana
and it's the [__] the dish that
managed to piss off the locals at the
Donkey Sanctuary [__] charitable
event what the [__] were you thinking
about putting banana and
chicken
together tell me so I can help you okay
um it was just using like a South
American kind of influences in and R
roasting chicken you didn't [__] tell
me the truth about the banana no and I'm
a chef and I've done my [__] homework
before I got here and let food taste of
what it
should it's not just mixing prawns with
chocolate and chicken with banana that's
the problem it's the other 70 dishes on
Lawrence's huge menu sit down I want to
replace it with a dozen dishes that he
can cook easily to stop the tourist
waiting hours for their dinner
have you have you come to terms with you
know trying to restrict the menu every
time I try to think about it I think of
the people that have asked for this
those particular items and why I
shouldn't take them off I do get some
return customers
so I must be doing something right but
where are these [__] then cuz I've
been here for three nights on the Trot
and I don't see the [__] return
business you give me the impression in
such a short period of time I've known
you that I've
got a young man that's playing with
these dad's money trying to [__] run
a
restaurant that's the impression I
get well nothing that's wrong cuz I
believeing what I'm doing is right if I
didn't I wouldn't be doing it I couldn't
do this [__] menu on my own with 72
dishes on there I couldn't do it because
you're not a [__] proper Chef so if
you're not a proper Chef then don't try
and cook out your box and unless that's
going to [__] sink in and stay in
your mind I've got no chance Lawrence is
refusing to reduce his huge menu but
it's the only way he'll ever coat with a
busy restaurant it's time to prove my
point for tonight's service I've devised
a three course Mediterranean menu that
will fly out the kitchen and get
customers served
quickly a gaspacho soup barbecued
chicken with a warm potato
salad and a roasted caramelized Peach
what's the twist there is no twist it's
all [__] local that's it there's no
twist there Y tonight customers will
order from Lawrence's alicart menu but
when he falls behind he'll switch to
mine and that will show him how quick he
can serve customers I just want him to
have that emergency menu yeah at the
Forefront of his mind set his ego apart
get that back in London and for him to
concentrate on sort of accomplishing a
fully booked service with no
complaints got an order for chocolate
prawns he said you know earlier no one
wants to buy chocolate prawns he thinks
it's [__] stupid idea first all that
came in chocolate prawns and carrot soup
so
um it's 9:00 and the orders from
Lawrence's huge menu of 72 dishes are
now flooding in but it's already
starting to go wrong medium yes yeah
look look look it's raw it's not pink
it's raw it's raw it's red raw all I
want you to do is just cook a [__]
Kebab property still live on to yeah
please right you in control yeah yeah
yeah that I'm not going to taste that
yeah but it looks
burnt Lawrence needs to push the button
now and replace his menu with my menu if
he's to avoid a repeat of last night
Fiasco you want to push the button no no
no seriously no no seriously yeah no you
sure yes yeah hey this is nothing to do
with your bollocks and size of your [__]
is it no Lawrence's reluctance to use my
emergency menu means it's the customers
who suffer and if I'm dead honest with
you the lamb is everyone's saying the
Lamb's bone dry ey it's apping really
really is
[Music]
apping yeah what happened to that one
there not hot enough that's not good
that's
raw but the complaint was that it was
cold yeah it's cold because it's what
war
why when meals start coming back
Lawrence finally
cracks right you right yeah you yeah
I've called your menu away you've called
it away yeah it's all done all you have
to do is call it away hey a Norman's
just got to put the [__] chicken on
the barbecue nothing more yes thank you
for pushing the [__]
button pushing out my emergency menu
should have been idiot proof but they've
left it too late and in the hands of Dum
and Dumber it descends into fast this is
why put in 25 minutes ago yeah and I'm
still try wa cuz I've had to send food
out I can't stop start stop start I'm
doing my next order which is two P cabs
and a chicken cab no don't I just ask
you I'm going to brush it I'm looking
for the
cloth come on man if the time I need to
pull your finger out now is right now
you know that hey I know yeah I've got
two pork kebabs to make but why are we
serving pork PAB when we've got the
emergency menu on I don't know ask the
waiter [__]
hell there's little point in asking
restaurant manager Alex you guys on top
of Step how are your tables do I need to
go to any tables at all he's so confused
as to who's ordered what he's now
serving food to tables with no one on
them no they should be here but they're
not
here okay go back to the
[Music]
kitchen this place right now is the
biggest [__] hole in Spain it's [__]
embarrassing cadell shitol at its
best
it's the worst meal we've ever
had it's qu to 12 now we we got here at
half n we just finished the main course
so it has been a long
way with customers worn out from
waiting meals been sent back and now
refunds been handed out surely even
Lawrence can see that by sticking to his
stupid menu he's only got himself to
blame name I'm speechless so I I I I I
don't know what to say let's get to the
Crux
Lawrence um I think Norman was put on
the fting much pressure tonight you know
he your menu made him plate up his own
plates and do the starters and the cold
soups out there on the barbie and he
couldn't manage slowed him down too much
um you're telling me that my menu [__]
him up on the grill he couldn't he
couldn't deal with it couldn't deal with
what what putting a [__] bowl of soup
hat that's already made for him that was
it was shown when are you guys going to
stop [__] around with
excuses when's one of you going to step
forward with a pair of bollocks and give
me some [__]
honesty cuz I know where you were cuz
that was [__]
shocking let me tell you
something you made a [__] good
decision you pushed the button whether
you like it or not it was too [__]
late an hour and a half late so who's
[__] f was it
now Chef I'm [__] out of
here [__]
[Music]
yourself well he wanted me to be honest
I told him what I
thought yeah maybe I should have led
with the whole with his whole
menu but that's
hindsight hindsight has never even done
this [__] project
[Music]
it's day five and there's storm clouds
over
leada I've never felt as bad about a
restaurant as I did last night and when
I walked out I wasn't sure I'd be coming
back pissing down but just when I
thought things couldn't get any worse
there was a Breakin and nearly £4,000
were stolen from the premises overnight
morning how you do yeah fine um first of
all sorry to hear about the news [__]
out it's not good it's not good at all
how much was it 5 half thousand years 5
half thousand
years hey she's not happy either well
she's not much of a [__] g dog is she
hey um and where's the where's the
safe it's not so much a safe but I
cashed in in a filing
cabinet been jimmied here and down the
sides it's still locked I haven't moved
or touched anything this is how I found
it when I came down you then got the the
money box inside here unbelievable
they've left the small notes they just
took the big ones I not been F it's the
filing
cabinet why would you leave 5 and a half
Grand in
there the most important rule for any
restaurant owner anywhere in the world
is always put your takings in the the
bank Jesus Christ I've got to think long
and hard whether I can actually continue
without that money and now that may be
the Clincher that you know I won't be
able to make
it it's not just a failing restant I'm
deaning with but I owner about to book
his flight home if ever there was a time
for Lawrence to realize that I'm here to
help it's now you know it's your
pride that you've got to stop [__]
worrying about cuz how [__] proud are
you going to feel at [__] Malaga
airport with your bags what are you
going to
do wa yeah seriously hello what the [__]
are you going to
do go home yeah go home with your
[__] cck between your
legs yeah yeah and what ring your mates
tell them what big [__] [__] you've
been in [__] Spain I don't go through
that kind of [__] to [__] help
turn the restaurant around I can't do it
without
you I've only one more chance to get
through to Lawrence and get him
listening to
[Music]
me you wouldn't go into a ball ring
without taking clear instruction from
someone who knows what they're talking
about
lawrencea listen to this man for the
next 5 minutes because um he's going to
show you some very very crucial moves
you Mot
I hope to God he ditches the arrogance
and listens to Matador Raphael more than
he's listened to
me big [__] Tes La now he's got to
stand on his own two feet and show me as
the Spanish would say your cahas show me
you've got a pair of bollocks and
[__] use
them have you got your gas sh yeah no
problemo where where currently tucked up
[Music]
inside
[__] you stay out the way watch
out [__] hell where's your
go oh it's a [__] it it's just a [__]
storm don't think um Spanish blls like
me very
much what am I doing oh [__] hell
that's not a good sign one thing he
doesn't need now they stubborn us here
we
go
get off your ass come on get
[Music]
up I'm not doing that come on get out of
here come on hey with Lawrence carefully
listening to Raphael's expert advice he
starts to get the hang of
it you know
I won
one you're right rule number six Running
a Restaurant in Spain is a risky
business it pays to listen to some
expert
advice [__] scary now yeah how'd you
feel um I feel like your Point's been
proven in a very big way you have a big
pair of konas now just [__] use them
yeah well done get some water yeah
[__] hell
now I've got Lawrence listening I need
to get him cooking like a proper Chef
every night Lawrence Cooks everything on
this plch of Grill to save time as a
result it all tastes the same fishy meat
and Meaty veg all you do now cook an egg
on there for
me whilst Lawrence fries an egg on the
plung of Grill I'm cooking mine in a
non-stick Frying Pan um I want to teach
him how his lazy way of cooking is
tainting everything he serves
up
okay that's just with an egg yeah what
I'm trying to get through is all that
there
yeah is
what carbonized food from thank you ages
and ages of beauty carbonized [__]
[__] and all I want you to do now is
start thinking about cooking in pans M
yeah I'm going to show Lawrence that in
the time it takes him to cook a whole
sea bream on his
grill he could fillet
it fry it and make a simple
Mediterranean Source what I'm trying to
do Lawrence yeah is make your life
[__] easier you know that yeah and
whilst I'm still waiting for yours I've
just got an
orange a lemon a pink grapefruit fresh
bzel are you cooked yet almost
out and
on
now I'm not trying to be some jumped up
[__] SMY ass little [__] I'm just
trying to explain you're busting your
bollocks the wrong way around because I
am not going to [__] listen to
[__] Tom Dick and AR telling me they
want to sit and [__] compete with
that or sit and eat that I know which
one you can do 10 times quicker and a
thousand times
better don't be scared to use a pan okay
do you understand he's drilled into me
my pride and you know my arrogance has
really shown through and I've been a bit
of an ass about it and bit stubborn and
you know I'm I'm really now excited that
he's here I really want to learn and and
get this place
moving the penny might have
dropped but now I've only got two days
to put things right out with the old
yeah in with a new [__] bin them yeah
we're short of coold
tonight with Lawrence finally letting go
of his huge menu it's time for a new
beginning in its place I've created a
small Mediterranean menu using local
produce five starters including figs and
Serano ham and watermelon with feta
cheese and six Mains including a pan
fried sea bream and a barbecued chicken
on a warm potato
salad actually cooking properly that
feels absolutely fantastic at last Lim
menu fresh ingredients absolutely
amazing the menu will offer Brit
something authentic fresh and above all
quick to
prepare and in reducing 72 dishes to 15
Service couldn't be any simpler for
restaurant manager
Alex okay what about this table here
8:30 booking I've just take the order
now okay good okay let's go yeah the
menu is simpler a lot easier we can do
volume now now we got a chance to put
the [__] thing right
it's my final night and it's the
relaunch of lear's new menu okay I've
only got one shot at this and I can't
afford any mistakes cook to changing you
tonight yeah you're yeah you're coming
off that barbecue yeah I want you
connected to the owner as a SF that's my
decision and I'm sticking to
it I'm putting sous chef Norm in the
kitchen prepping cold
starters and pot washer Tom will take
his place on on the barbecue chicken
it's a gamble but I'm confident Tom will
send the meat out
cooked all you have to do is take the
chicken off the barbecue yep and put it
onto the plate and send it yeah sure
good you guys set this evening isn't
just about launching a new menu is about
Lawrence regaining his reputation with
the British xack
Community 6 months ago he hosted a
fundraising dinner for the local Donkey
Sanctuary serving Frozen starters and
chicken stuff with banana it was a
fiasco tonight I convinced them to come
back it's very nerve breing having them
here because I know how much I upset
them last time and I know how much
distaste they have for the restaurant in
general and it's really nerve-wracking
for me to be able to know that i' I've
got to cook for them and cook them
really really well tonight will be the
test whether or not the food's edible
that would be a good
start with customers getting their food
on time the relaunch is off to a good
start
it's quite refreshing to have something
different and not the same sort of
chicken or fish with fries a lot better
than last year yeah phenomenal nothing's
come back everything's cooked
beautifully yeah to be honest so far
it's been a breath of fresh
air right donkey sanct just sat down yes
yep okay we're on their starters now
treat that table like a time bomb the
starters arrived for the Donkey
Sanctuary but just when I thought it was
all going to plan Alex has forgotten to
serve the wine how do we put the
starters down without serving the
wine um of all tables come
on at 9:00 the restaurant's full but
bizarrely there's a backlog of people
waiting for
tables it's Alex's responsibility to get
them seated but he's flapping around
like a headless
chicken what's going on with this
[__] table that's waiting the bar for
so long table six Table Six yeah I to
booked at you see at the start of the
night and I had to tell him that you
know we need to have the table back
who did you tell you need the table back
the customer the customer what about the
[__]
kitchen they need to know first cuz they
got to cook it yeah so then move your
ass
sir for some bizarre reason Alex has got
tables double booked within an hour no
one can to eat anything within an hour
embarrassing I mean [__]
embarrassing Alex has simply got greedy
in thinking they can turn tables around
in an
hour as a result people are turning up
for the reservations but I have nowhere
to
sit and in the Kitchen Lawrence is now
struggling with a backlog of
orders donkey c table on top of all that
Alex has now gone into meltdown Al get a
grip Alex you can do it Alex do
it you can [__] do
it we're waiting on you I know you're
waiting on me and I really appreciate
this this is [__] critical you know
go come on
please we waited for 40 minutes for
starter then sat with dirty plates for
45 minutes and then we were asked to
leave the table because the next lot of
um guests arrived five place here 1 2 3
4 5
five although Under Pressure Lawrence is
at least coping with my reduced menu yep
you got three Sano three watermelon yet
finish those off in a minute soon as I
get these
out I can only be grul that Lawrence got
the Donkey Sanctuary main courses out
before the [__] hit the fan very very
nice I mean it was a lot nicer than
chicken banana I must do it the food is
actually very good um I think
everybody's quite pleased with the food
if he can come up with this sort of deal
yes we'll be back again but the service
leaves leaves quite a little bit to be
desired I think a lot more work on the
service me a red it's the end of the
evening and Lawrence's cooking has been
a
success but Alex's double booking
madness has let everyone
down we're So Close
Alex so
close you can do better I know I can do
better you can do better I know I can do
better turn around and tell him that
he's paying your
salary [__] tough night a real tough
night 87 covers and it was a struggle
and the service was [__] pretty
dismal however the Donkey Sanctuary have
confirmed they're going to come back
that speaks volumes that means the local
community are now back on their side and
quite frankly you can't ask for a more
crucial time for them to support it
because we're just about to come out the
summer season and enter the [__]
winter and without their support they
won't get through the
winter in 6 days I've finally seen a
change at leada but once I've gone
Lawrence is only 4 weeks until the end
of the season to make the money that
will help him survive the
winter
remember do not cut corners and don't
make a [__] ass of
yourself look a St reminder to make sure
the standards never slip don't make a
[__] ass of yourself that's gone that
is [__]
gone goodbye
okay I only hope lear's doors will still
be open when I
[Music]
return in the summer I spent a week at
laara the bana on the cadel soul it was
holiday hell that's not cool that's
RW former nightclub manager Lawrence
Davey was up to his eyes in debt he had
swinging
kebabs someone taking the piss prawns in
chocolate sauce I thought it was [__]
hideous
and his dishes with a Twist had pissed
off the Brits ising really really is a
ping Lawrence was so stubborn he
wouldn't give up his huge menu without a
fight no you sure yes yeah hey this is
nothing to do with your B size your [__]
is it
no after knocking some sense into him I
created a set menu of just 15 authentic
Mediterranean
dishes and on the launch night we won
back the local EXP trade that Lawrence
had lost if he can come up with this
sort of deal yes we'll be back
[Music]
again 4 weeks later I'm back on the
Costa it's late September and most of
the tourists have packed up and gone
home the beachfront restaurants are
deserted and N feels like a ghost
town I only hope laara is fairing
better good to see you and you yeah
how's the month been busy very very busy
ready yeah almost double last year so
that's [__] great news good to see
you you too how have you been really
good yeah it's been great yes busy it
has been busy and you're working hard
yes yes less flustered yes more
organized we're organized we're happy
we're communica and what's the special
Kebab tonight the special Kebab uh
special Kebab is in the bin great donkey
dick Babs are off the menu Norm still in
the kitchen preparing cold starters good
to see you my man and out on the Terrace
is Tom the former pot washer now
promoted as the barbecue
chef and has Norman S out here again or
is this your domain this my domain this
is your
domain but best of all Lawrence is no
longer cooking on the pler
grill haven't used it in about 3 you
haven't used the pun of Grill touched it
thank you [__] hell really mean that
yeah you must miss it no no no I did I
did for about a we I kept on going back
to it thinking [__] where's my steak and
it was always in the oven where should
we s perfect considering it's the end of
the season leara is reassuringly
busy everything seems to be running more
efficiently there's an air of calmness
around it and yeah it's a nice bust
which is lovely everything's gleaming
it's spotless the menu is no longer the
size of a telephone directory it's one
page and there are even some new dishes
for me to try I was a little bit cocky
in um that I he love my food when he
first got here this time around um I
know that I really really want to
impress him now with these dishes if I
can't impress him now then you know I've
really [__] it up here we are here is
the squid and Sh thank you for my
starter I've chosen barbecue squid and
shizo sausage on a better
rocket it's nicely cooked it's not too
chewy and the srio sausage just gives it
that little spice that squid knees
and that's what you come to Spain for
dishes like
this for my main course I've chosen seab
bass on a bed of cream leaks one of the
new dishes on Lawrence's Autumn
[Music]
menu there's just no comparison to what
I was fed a month ago where it's just
really nice clean simple honest food and
that's what this place needed without
any stupid [__] twist four weeks ago
Lawrence was £75,000 in debt equivalent
to
€2,000 and laara was on the verge of
closing
down what really shocked me about
tonight's dinner is I can't believe it
was the same guy that was cooking my
dinner a month
ago that was delicious thank it's an
absolute pleasure to cook in here now
and I you know I'm not angry I'm not
upset I'm just you know cooking the food
I love cooking and and seeing empty
plates come back clean and and happy
customers leaving the restaurant you
took
€3,000 this time a year ago now you're
on €9,000 what have you knocked off on
the debt um I've knocked off1
13,000 since you were here last Cash
Cash already yeah what do you need to do
a night to stay open during the winter
how many covers during the winter 20 20
so already tonight with 33 or 34 in for
dinner yeah we're we're not home and dry
but we're [__] making great
Headway
don't you [__] dare stop yeah and
every time you think of stopping turn on
the plch of Grill yeah deep fry your
[__] vegetables and [__] hit them
on there never again good
night
Tom that was value for money delicious
straightforward local produce cooked
properly and he's not trying to be too
[__] clever and if he can continue
doing that he's got a strong chance of
surviving the winter and opening up next
[__] season ready to attack it with
some money in the bank thank God for
that the [__] penny has finally
[Music]
dropped
time's running out for the fenig arms a
country Pub that thinks it's clares is
this Pub
frood because I can't quite believe I'm
[__] standing in a traditional
English pub this week I'm trying to help
the most stubborn fruit cake I've ever
met I love B now where did that one come
from 7 days to teach this old dog some
new tricks just remember we are the
bosses it will take a Miracle [__]
come and tell me yeah cuz I'll smash
them over your [__]
[Music]
head Theon Valley a wealthy farming area
in the heart of the Lancashire
Countryside home of the hot pot and the
custard tart and a great location for a
roadside Pub
so I'm looking for the fenic
arms a good old traditional English PB
every day thousands of punters speed
past the pub it's slap bang on the busy
a683 between Lancaster and Kirby
londsdale
pubs are now the nation's favorite place
to eat out and Brian Ray has spent the
last 30 years cooking pub food I don't
claim to be God I don't claim to be
Jesus but in my business and in my
kitchen my word is law there's a mint to
be made if you get pub food right but
since Brian and his partner Elaine Howen
took over the fenig arms 3 years ago
they've been Heming money at a rate of,
1500 quid a
week what's going on up there one big
overgrown Bush font me and here is the
menu
okay this is elae elae nice to see you
and hello I'm Brian Brian how are you oh
I'm fine it's good delighted to meet you
likewise good to see you very delighted
God it's tight in here isn't it yep so
where's the um where's the restaurant
dining areas this way follow us down
then this is supposed to be a
traditional English pub but it's full of
tacky clutter and when it comes to table
settings Brian's got serious delusions
of
grandeur God
extraordinary not what I imagined as a
pub um we used to have this just as a
small dining room with four tables in it
God looks like we've got the queen
coming for [__] dinner
now unfortunately no one's coming for
dinner but it's not for want of trying
Brian and Elaine are throwing everything
at this failing business we spend most
of our life down here anything between
120 hours a week down here 120 hours a
week 60 hours each yeah no no 120 each
so what days off did you take we don't
we don't you don't take days off we had
we had Christmas day off this year that
was your last day off yep and the day
before that was the previous Christmas
and the day before that would have been
about 18 years ago Jesus six days off
for a quad heart
bypass but I was back at work on the
seventh day
[__] you back at work seven days later
yeah yep seven days after the op I was
back working in the kitchen cookie are
you mad probably how old are you 62
Christ Ryan is killing himself over an
empty Pub this place should feel
laidback and Lively but it's got all the
formality and awkwardness of a
wake it stayed you know the atmosphere
is static and very
and
dreary so manyu for this evening thank
you plus the additions of the day
careful
wiist Ryan calls them additions rather
than specials doesn't like to call them
specials [__]
man I say but it's far from being a pub
man us it I God red Johnson's confair
goard duck breast Ribble Farmhouse
seavoy cabbage rosty potato Willington
crispy Apple chuty calos
you [__]
me Brian's trying way too hard and his
list of pompous sources is
ridiculous I mean there's pure Mera red
wine sauce je Cal je Lanos je
caramelized onions
tartar
extraordinary you walk into a pub and
you expect a stinking the pudding and
shepherd's
pie I've ordered the simplest thing on
the menu a CRA salad but Brian doesn't
do
simple we'd like to point out first and
foremost we're a traditional Old English
pup Hy hell what that's steeped in
Tradition there isn't
it let's see if Brian can get
traditional with my main course but I'm
doubtful it's Cocker and rack of lamb
balsamic cherry tomatoes and one of
those pretentious sauces
how the [__] did you get in how do you
get the lamb
out not only is this not pub food but
it's plain
awful honestly it's like chewing a
[__] golf ball Brian's got a lot to
answer for this is a pub isn't it yes
and that's what I had to keep on telling
myself a traditional Old English pub so
how many pubs have you been in that have
served a over reduced syrup be sickly B
with vinegar in a zed shape over a
square
plate probably none a pub or Pub grub is
the next step up from from home no it's
that basic rustic honest good British
solid food and there's nothing
traditional about what you're doing here
this is currently running as a
restaurant that is
confused over the top I mean absurd
beyond belief
you're not running a pub it feels like
you're running a
restaurant
badly modern pub food is all about
simple home cooking dumb well but I
don't think it's going to be easy
persuading Brian and Elaine that they
need to get back to basics how you
feeling totally
crap uh it was pretty devastating last
night um some of the things yes we could
fully accept and take um but to be quite
honest the way we felt
if you have to be like that to get to
the top I'm glad I'm at the bottom I've
got to be brutally honest clearly you
don't like that level of honesty I'm not
here for confrontation and you know if
you're that devastated on the back of
what you've been through in this
industry for 30 years I'm surprised
you're so weak after 30 years hard graft
Brian and Elaine should be reaping the
benefits but in fact they're facing
bankruptcy and could be homeless in 3
months they've got to face facts
how much um are you in
debt when we actually sat down and wrote
it down tossed it all up uh put
everything into it where you sort of
leave things out so that you don't see
it uh we're about quarter of a million
in
it if we had to close tonight
uhhuh the situation at the fenic arms is
desperate I need to find out how Brian
runs his
kitchen
since his heart up his memory lets him
down so he sets a timer for every dish
he's cooking and that helps you not to
forget when it's ready but it's not just
that it's giving you awareness all the
time that time's passed so how many
times have you got going on just one at
the
moment three times
[Music]
three Ryan short-term memory is as awful
as the rich sticky sauce is coating
every
dish and this one and that I believe is
a previous scrumpy reduction um we
actually didn't have a lot of cider so
it's the scrumpy reduction without the
scrumpy Apple ties
reduction with apple ties in
[Music]
there Apple
ties [__] me I feel
sick I'm starting to realize nothing
about this kitchen makes sense you got
any Mash ready for us Nate and we got a
bow for that while Brian runs around the
tiny cramped space he's paying top whack
to his most experienced Chef Nathan who
seems to just put pass in
everything is this normal when someone
taking a piss at me this is normal
normal I've never seen such a chaotic
and inefficient kitchen and on top of
that there's Brian's over complicated
and frankly ridiculous food don't call
Pate it's don't call lettuce piping hot
pigeon red wine sauce
parley hey you've got a [__] brain
haven't you I hope so I like to think so
is this pub food no because I can't
quite believe I'm [__] standing in
the traditional English
pub Brian's already had five heart
attacks and he's running himself into
the ground cooking the wrong food in the
wrong
way your kitchen is a disaster Zone it
is [__] impossible to get food out of
there
I tell you what big boy you may be 62
but [__] me you don't have to work that
hard you know that it'd be nice if I
didn't I I swear to God cuz that must be
a [__] nightmare in
there the fenic arms in Lancashire has
ideas above its
station it's a country pub with
aspirations to be a fancy restaurant the
dining room is set for the queen and the
food is is
pretentious Brian Ray and elae Howden
are over A4 of a million pounds in debt
but they're still
spending you got a setup of a restaurant
big coffee machine espresso expensive
bit of quit this no uh I picked up for
400 400 quid yeah you bought it yeah
from where eBay eBay
yeah Brian stuffed his kitchen with so
much secondhand equipment you can't
swing a cat let me just squeeze past
here thank [__] you're small you know
that it's anet of time I know what
that's what you do you look for chefs on
eBay look at their size their
measurements their weight then employ
them
yes Brian's DIY kitchen is a cramped
botg together disaster Zone held
together with bits of
string and his whing problem goes much
deeper than I first
thought I I love plates whereas other
people go and have a holiday or go out
for a meal I'll save my pennies and buy
a
[Music]
plate Jesus [__] me look all those
plates there wrapped in clil why are
they wrapped in clinfield stay clean
just stay clean
yeah right what are these plates used
for just some I bought to play with some
you bought to play with yeah we haven't
played with them yet just got the chance
of getting them so I got them what you
think we putting in there salad sou I
don't know we'll come up with some dish
and use them for that no no no no come
on you don't serve food in them do you
yes we did oh no come on I wouldn't put
a [__] dog's dinner in there you
don't serve food in them uh we have done
in the past no look at the size of
it they're big I mean you you can you
can go tiling with that thing you know
that we can retile this whole
establishment with these plates just
look what we can start doing in terms of
look
already it's starting to look unique
isn't it yep and so you said what what
what Chinese dish on this one it wasn't
it was a Japanese dish Christ a
m the tile glue didn't stick
[__] all right don't worry it was
chipped anyway sorry damn damn damn damn
damn damn damn damn every corner I turn
I discover another of Brian stashi
squired
away now where did that one come from I
bought that from villoy
[__] hell and what's that you don't
serve food on that come on yes we do
it's like a [__] swimming pool for
Barbie now we've got one with three
compartments down the side we served the
steak on that you served the steak on
that
yep a lifetime of hoarding calls for
shock
treatment for the first time ever we're
going to get rid of that [__]
junk before I can even think about
changing the food I've got to make some
space condemned broken chipped skip yeah
yeah this where did you get this thing
from eBay
eBay tucked away in the corner Ryan's
got a huge disgusting stock pot it's the
base for all his revolting sources
that's going to go in the skip we don't
need to [__] have the shz the Merlot
we don't need it that for me is a
Hazard do we need that hot plate um well
it's usually a way of keeping the food
hot Brian's been collecting kitchen
equipment for 30 years he's never thrown
anything away and even with me here to
help he's finding it
difficult bit of a shock to the
system it's a hell of a shock to the
system some of these items here you're
going to keep some of them here you're
going to sell and some of you're going
to Che Chuck pined tag on there left to
his own devices I know Brian would put
all this junk back so I'm forcing him to
decide how much of it is actually
essential to running the kitchen I don't
want to get rid of that yet there I just
want to keep that top it's a table top
don't want to get rid of that oh dear
he's hopeless keep them CU I have to
find somewhere for them how many
microwaves do we need just G one or two
three
can what you do with three microwaves
one one and one spare I've been trying
to get rid of some of this rubbish for
two or 3 years but Brian will not part
with
anything I'm leaving Elaine in charge of
rebuilding the kitchen while I make sure
that Brian's junk has gone for
good okay why do you think I brought you
here I have no idea you got no idea want
see that skip behind there that's full
of your
junk and I'm really worried the fact
that you're going to put half that junk
back in your kitchen so I've got to get
rid of it once and for all go on get
that stck pot
away we're getting rid of the
[__] look at
it stop holding
crap I think youve well and truly made
the
point the harsh truth is that 20 rural
pubs close every month and if Brian and
Elaine don't want to add to that number
they need to start making some drastic
changes got a huge amount of respect for
[__] Brian the guy is's 62 years of
age he's been cooking for 30 years he
hasn't got a [__] pot to piss in he's
working in excess of 120 hours a [__]
week in the kitchen I'm sorry but FR man
at
62 that can kill
you clearing out the junk was just the
beginning in before I can start changing
that god- awful food I need to get this
kitchen working properly look at the
space you got here like that hey we're
going to throw a [__] dance in here
in a
minute I've got to do something drastic
I need to clear out one final thing from
the
kitchen
Brian Brian big night for you tonight
don't be scared of a change you're not
cooking in the kitchen tonight you are
out of the kitchen for good and you are
more capable of running your Pub but not
from the kitchen as a proper Publican as
a proper
host I will do my best please go and get
changed I
will I think this kitchen has got a
better chance without Brian he's got a
young but enthusiastic team of Three
Chefs Nathan Karen and Chris I know how
difficult Brian is to work with that is
so [__] obvious yeah he's gone now
yeah he's not running the kitchen he's
is running his business show him that
you can do
it it's essential that the fic arms has
a friendly couple out front to do is
keep all allting St on but I'm not
convinced Brian will be up to the job
after 30 years behind the
stove good evening did anybody tell you
we've run out of sea bass and we've only
got one Tian
left right anybody any ideas on what
you're looking for before we run out
of what's
left oh dear not exactly a polished
performance that way talk to them Brian
they won't
bite but it's looking much more
professional in the kitchen where Karen
has taken charge
CHS one Chen
don't worry about drizzling the plate
just Source the [__] thing please
there you
go
good even with Brian's complicated menu
the food is flying out of the kitchen
just like it should do in a
pub they're doing a great job in there
now the problem's in the dining room and
there's no Vibrance
there the atmosphere is stuffy and
formal why Earth is he l pouring the
wine this is supposed to be a
pub while Brian and Elaine fuss over
their customers they empty tables in the
dining room and the bar is filling up
with people waiting to
[Music]
eat they're never going to make a profit
running it like this they need to fill
the tables twice a
night what's happening in the bar
everyone's sitting in there taking
orders get them straight to the [__]
table get them in the restaurant clear
the bar can I pass you some menus are
these ladies part of your
party Ryan has got to loosen up or
they'll never speed up the
service first of all you guys yeah
[__] well done I mean really well
done my problem was in the dining room
your service doesn't need to be that
formal if you relax the service will
relax and that's not nitpicking we're a
pub yeah what's wrong with them carrying
their own drinks through to the table
nothing you know yourself where the
atmosphere is not right you know it's
not running smoothly of course you do
but we need to work on that level of
just a
pup I've only got 3 Days To Go and I've
still got to solve the biggest problem
at the fenig arms Brian's
food what is
traditionally English pub food what is
it I suppose English pub food is
basically scampy gamon
sausage that but that isn't what I want
to be that's nothing of the sort [__] me
what pubs have you been in um not quite
so many since I ended up in one myself
it's rustic simple English cooking
whether it's a bowl of split pea soup
whether it's lisher Hot Pot whether it's
steak and chips it is simple
food and that's where I've lost my way
then it's time I push Brian in the right
direction see this on
here twaddle yeah absolute horrendous
waffle I don't want to see the madira
sauce the Citrus mayonnaise I don't want
to see a cal no more sources the pub
will be serving great British pub
food I've got to start replacing some of
Brian's dishes with good home cooking
yeah yeah what's wrong with having
Lancashire hot pot on the menu nothing
nothing at all where are we Lan Lancer
and so why is that not on the
menu I've asked Brian and elae to
rewrite the menu minus the waffle pound
fried duck livers just fried duck
liers fish can um just put down fish
cake potatoes on top lots of potatoes
yeah spread nice good give it a little
twist at the bottom like that that mixes
the onions and the potatoes yeah up on
top and in what have you done for the
fish cake salmon and hadock fish cake oh
salmon hadock fish cake salmon and
hadock fish cake yeah and that's it yep
wow finally we're getting somewhere I
feel like we're really starting to
[__] understand what Pub
means progress at last but I don't think
they really understand what a pub is
until they've been to
one so I'm giving them the night off
their first Saturday Night Out in 18
years good uh right
Elaine uh
Brian take the dogs for a walk don't
worry about the service right when you
come back okay get changed yeah and come
and have dinner when was last time you
sat in here on a Saturday night and
watched your staff at work and enjoyed
your dinner never never right okay off
you go thank you guys see you later than
you yeah see you later right now one
last thing you're the only Pub in
Britain that's got a [__] uniform get
changed into your civis see in 5 minutes
ready to run the place
yeah there's a good
boy there's a good point come on
Lane I'm hoping that if Brian and Elaine
experiened a real Pub atmosphere they'll
realize relaxed is best so tonight
there'll be no fussy service at the
fenick
arms good evening good evening good
evening welcome to fing arms how are you
very well thank you good good good
uh you can't come
in you too busy um no we're not too busy
um you're not here to receive an OB
you're here to have dinner you're
dressed to formal we'll go back again as
quick as you can right come on Lovely
we've never been out ever not dressed
like this right come back with something
[Music]
casual welcome to the fenic arms come
through please thank
you cheers
[Music]
D tonight they'll be saing the first of
my new real Pub grub not a sticky you
inside it's a rather nice color isn't
it you want to taste this Patty
it's
good with
that
that that is to die for the food has
been a hit I Hope they've finally got
the message that they've got nothing to
fear from Going Back to Basics you've
got to show flexibility and you can do
it and getting you out of this place
today was a breath fresh air just to
relax the place and the more you can
relax I swear to God you're going to see
your business
grow last night was a success I thought
the fenic arms was back on track but
this morning I've discovered Brian has
gone behind my back and jeopardized
everything we've been trying to achieve
we had a really good night last night
and the staff worked [__]
exceptionally well um straight after I
left um Brian came downstairs and
started being a tanker old
bat um right I'm just going to have a
word with him yeah in fact both of them
cuz I'm getting a little bit pissed off
and thene my back's turned what was his
complaint to you this morning um it was
generally that um he doesn't want to see
any of his plates being bin he doesn't
want anything being different he came
around took all his knives out um it was
just generally um this is our business
this is our home things aren't going to
be changing as much as anybody thinks
we're still going to be doing it our way
and nobody's going to say any different
he stuck in his ways I'm pissed off
really I have ped off fire scale of 1 to
yeah give be a good seven
unbelievable two days to go and he
decides to screw it all up at 62 years
of age it's becoming really [__]
clear that you can't teach an old dog
new [__]
tricks I'm nearing the end of my week at
the fenic arms where I'm trying to save
Brian and Elaine from the jaws of
bankruptcy but just when I thought we'd
turn the corner Brian's gone behind my
back and told he star he won't accept my
changes I want to get it out with you
now because I don't mind going I'd
rather go and see my wife today and sit
here and [__] bang my head against
the wall if you're not prepared to
accept the changes you've got to tell me
and the
nitpicking you do you know what you
you've got to balance it out with some
confidence and a little bit of
encouragement as we I said to them this
this morning right just remember we are
the bosses it's not a power struggle you
are definitely the owners just cut them
a little slack you'll be surprised you
know what we're acting like small
children aren't we thank you they're
busting their nuts off for you right now
they're busting their nuts off for you
right now that's not for me that's for
you because you pay their [__]
salaries not me and when you worried
about your villero and B [__] plates
that no one's changing [__] come and
tell me yeah cuz I'll smash them over
your [__]
head
he better have listened this time I'm
only here for two more days and a bigger
concern is that it's Sunday on a bank
holid weekend and the pub is virtually
empty um Sunday lunch normally this
quiet or Sunday lunch is bit hitting
there some weeks you can have quite a
few in other weeks you can have maybe
six or 10 in here we are SAT quter 2 25
kill done I mean we should be having a
second seating coming in now for
lunch but thank God only 25 people are
going to eat the miserable looking roast
they're serving
today it's coated in yet another
disgusting brown sauce is that Brian's
recipe yeah yeah it's a revolting
coction of gravy granules and reduced
red wine I may have kicked Brian out of
the kitchen but unfortunately his
influence still lingers on I suppose we
can always [__] retile the roof on
that [__] can't we look at that F me
why is it so
dark but the yire puddings are actually
pretty impressive what a shame they're
going to be ruined by Brian's disgusting
gravy why isn't this place packed out
for a Sunday lunch we don't know we just
don't
know we have no idea it's um we've tried
different menus we've had bigger we've
had shorter we've tried all sorts yeah
look how busy the [__] road is yeah
you should be [__] ramming them in
Sunday lunch
yep turnover needs to increase by at
least 2,000 a week I think Sunday lunch
holds the key to solving the problem but
there's only one thing Brian's gravy is
good for yeah we're saying goodbye to
the gloop hello to
gravy we [__] hell we got some
Tac okay yeah one thing we going to do
now is make a proper gravy yes when was
the last time we made a proper gravy uh
years ago years ago yeah fresh oil in
there yeah and carrots leaks celery yeah
yeah and it's really important to make
the gravy in the tray the meat was
roasted
in and now stock be stock yeah bring
that up to the
boil right and when I when I pass this
through a SI want to see the bottom of
the tray yeah nice and clean yeah what
happens all the vegetables start to go
through the SI so it naturally thickens
the gravy out and look
gravy this has given me a great PR idea
that's going to appeal to Brian's
eccentric personality and give the fenic
arms the Boost it so desperately needs
that was an over buil lunch was it know
and we took how
much
i60 something 400 quid 1 2 3 4 5 6 78
eight of us on there barely enough to
pay the wages barely enough yeah the
penny dropped for me today you know that
why can't this place become
famous for
gravy brilliant idea look at these
things they're amazing you've got the
amazing potential to have a fantastic
Sunday lunch bring back real gravy this
place will be [__]
heaving yes how you go you get on the
street and you just announce okay
that you you've got a campaign to launch
real gravy at the [__] F arms yes a
campaign to launch real gravy hey it
sounds a little bit [__] D but why
can't you just just turn it around and
get out on the street with the team yeah
yes give us a word yes we will launch
the campaign
rip as I hoped Brian is well and truly
sold on the campaign join the campaign
for real
gravy join the fenic arms for real
gravy is groups armed with Yorkshire
puddings and jugs of gravy and we're
ready to hit the streets of Kirby
longsdale Yorkshire pudding and just a
little bit of campaign for real
gravy real gravy there we are no more
shoes no more sauces real
gravy no more syrups no more vinegars
just real traditional British
gravy oh yeah bollock sto bollocks to
Maggie the campaign for real gravy
starts at the Ben
Captain the center of the universe for
real gravy
nice good man gravy we want gravy we
want
gravy this D we want real gravy we want
great Word of Mouth publicity is
unbeatable and Brian and the team have
done a brilliant job making Dam Shaw the
f arms is the Talk of the Town we want
gravy we want gravy not just any gravy
but the real
gravy we relaunch tomorrow and when word
spreads about the real gravy the pub
should be packed out you are join our
campaign real
gravy it's my last day and there's still
a lot to do before tonight's relaunch
First Impressions count so there's no
point launching a big PR campaign pain
if the place looks a dump when the
punters get here have a look at that
sign it cheapens the place and it just
sends the wrong messages you know that
huh and I want to see the Fig arm so
that Banner you know that's got to go
and the whole place just needs sprucing
up a little bit jet hose the front and
just get it nice and
vibrant while the front of house team
spruce up the exterior I've suggested to
that he gets back on eBay and starts
selling off his huge Crockery
[Music]
collection I've got 10 of those and
they're starting off at 46 good
each I may have done the impossible and
got Brian selling his plates but I got a
feeling he won't find staying out the
kitchen so easy I need Elaine to keep an
eye on him when I'm
gone there's one person that can make
sure that he doesn't go back to his old
ways is you yeah I shall I shall remind
him I think he'll listen you've got to
keep him keep out of that kitchen you
you cannot let him back in there I just
think he was frightened of
being um jobless just put on the shelf
and forgotten about and he he didn't
want to feel as though they could manage
without him even though he knew that
it's the same with me but he's got that
competition streak in him he's 62 though
he doesn't need to be that competitive
with his staff no he doesn't but you
could see the passion he's had oh God 30
years yeah yeah easily like I said
there's not many that have lasted that
long but it's about time we started to
enjoy it a little bit
[Music]
now tonight we're relaunching the fenic
arms as a Great British
pub the real gravy campaign has done the
trick bookings have been pouring in all
day good afternoon Fric arms on a normal
Tuesday night Brian and elae would be
lucky to get 20 customers but there's
already 88 booked in for tonight's
relaunch 8:00 yeah we could maybe do it
going on towards half past in the
kitchen I've put together a new menu of
non nonsense tasty British pub favorites
there's hearty PE and ham soup and the
alltime classic a simple prawn cocktail
few Pawns in the middle yeah what's the
secret behind the pawn cocktail good
pawns good prawns lovely marroad sauce
and a little bit of Apple the Apple and
the lettuce yeah just really make it
nice and zesty all these dishes use
great ingredients prepared simply and
presented without fuss just like this
pressed ham terine when you think about
something like a puff you know it's it's
rustic to keep the food rustic yeah so
in terms of presentation dots and
[__] bits and Bobs get it on there
that's it end the
story all the chefs have impressed me
this week but I think C's got the
maturity to run the kitchen so you going
to take the rains yep you are yeah yeah
definitely and what happens if he starts
to change things again what are you
going to do put your foot down o go away
you put your foot down yeah
yeah it's time to show Brian and elae
their new menu I've replaced their
complicated fussy food with 25 classic
Pub
dishes surprise surprise simple
straightforward honest British pub food
yeah and nothing too quirky I'm well
impressed roast rib of beef stunning
your puddings Jugger gravy fish and
chips beautiful sausage and mash
Lancashire Hot Pot an apple and
blackberry crumble I'm proud of what I
can see the secret behind this menu here
and being completely traditional in
terms of pub food is just the speed it
can fly out it
yeah with two sittings in the dining
room the chefs will be under pressure
but it's Brian and any Lane I'm worried
about if they can't relax and speed up
the service we'll be
screwed do we say our prayers
now I'm shaking like a leaf
inside I don't know whether on this
planet next planet but I'm definitely on
a traditional Pub
Planet he better be the pub is packed
out tonight but if Brian and elae are
going to start paying off their huge
debts this can't be a
oneoff 60 minutes from the start of the
main for game two roast beef keep first
[Music]
T Rapido here we
go last those C
webs for the first time ever they're
aiming to fill the dining room twice
over so they can't waste time pouring
wine or gravy for the customers
tonight Mr Foster yes you've got him on
table
fall oh he need to be on three sorry did
you wait
No 5 minutes perfect gravy you happy
with gravy your pudding sensation
fantastic so far so good the kitchen
seems to be coping well under pressure n
just be careful all these main cses
flying out now desserts next right how
many have we done gu about 40ish maybe
about 45 just going up to 50 yeah over
halfway yeah keep it going
yes but out front there's a disaster
waiting to happen it's 8 30 and they're
slipping into Old Habits the bar is full
of people waiting to be seated Brian and
elae haven't got the first customers off
the tables
yet uh Brian we got a bit of a q forming
yeah can we sit some guest down yes we
just trying to get them to move the
tables sit them down if they don't move
where's the
r um I'll get somebody to bring the Bild
for you thanks we've got to get them out
of these tables now you know that's we
got to be firm now
yes what we finding harder to transition
is not a resturant PB yep so don't be
scared after 1 1 hour 55 minutes would
you mind taking coffee in the bar or
coming have a drinking the bar change
those tables if you don't do that in the
next 15 minutes we're going to be in the
[__]
ship have you got a bill for table that
one whichever one it
is it's been touch and go but at last
the second sitting are at their tables
that's the hardest thing right now isn't
it got to turn around and for the first
time ever it's starting to run like a
pub the f arms is
buzzing the real gravy is being lapped
up and traditional pub food has hit the
spot I had roast be and it was so
gorgeous with real gravy on it
nice
lovely if Brian and Lane can keep up the
pace they might just pull this
off I mean hell it's it's a lot of
excitement the adrenaline is absolutely
pounding through me evening all
fine it's fine it's been a huge success
and finally the pennies dropped for
Brian he's realized that the kitchen
runs better without
him I think the team have just been un
bloody
believable they've done it I've not been
there I've not had to come in and
where's this where's that where the
other and I am just so proud of them all
wow what a night at times this week I've
seriously doubted it was possible but
tonight the fenic arms has been
transformed from a stuffy dining room
into a vibrant packed
[Music]
Pub how much money do we
take the till y tells me we've done
2,447 yes get
in fantastic 2,000 more than last Sunday
lunch y Brian what does that tell you
changing the menu and doing it simpler
has worked yeah well since I've been
here that was the first night I
witnessed all of you running a pub and
I'm not going to come back to what I
came and saw a week ago yes no you're
not no no Chef whites no knife rack NOP
nowhere near it no no um there was one
one little problem I found a Barbie
plate please Eddie wrap it up in CL film
dig a hole and hide it yes promise me y
good man
go oh
no
[Applause]
[Music]
Edie a month ago I left Brian and Elaine
running a busy Pub I'm dying to find out
if they've kept it
up I'm on my way back to surprise them
for Sunday
lunch the car part's looking full always
a good sign and the last Sunday I was
here they struggled to serve 22
people good Campa for real gravy still
there menu we can notice at this
time good evening good afternoon hello
how are you fine thank you and yourself
yep very indeed thank
you where's Brian in the kitchen kitchen
he's where in the kitchen he's in the
kitchen with L what in the [__] is going
on
28 what in the [__] are you doing in
here hello hello I thought you were
doing the Great Northern run what are
you doing dressing those working why cuz
I haven't got anybody else oh for God's
sake car and Chris's day off today so
I'm on my own it turns out just one week
after I left Brian was back in the
kitchen and Nathan left to go back to
college oh [__] me Brian yes go I I
cannot believe I've just found you back
in the kitchen couldn't get any stuff
and we're just trying to recruit to
replace the one who
went bloody hell what else is back
truthfully before I start rumaging
around and looking for it some of the
plates oh no yep some of the
plates that was oh
no why because what you taught us was
listen to your customer oh here we go so
so we did so your customers are saying
Bring Back Square plates no what they
wanted was the wow factor on the food
again that's what they wanted what do
you mean the wow factor on the food it's
a PB Brian yes but if you're starting to
become a restaurant slowly within a
month you're destined for trouble we
went a little way down the road but kept
the menu basically along the lines of
what you were
saying PR cocktail still on there yes
yeah we've changed that you've changed
it we done the it's not in the wine
glass no um we've done it the way that
we've always done it and it sells
exceptionally well oh here we go how did
you used to serve the porn cocktail
before I put it in a glass remind me uh
scop shell with it on scop shell but it
sells and the customes like it Brian y
prawns don't live inside scallop shells
nope but they don't live inside glasses
either oh
oh [__] me [__]
hell the good news is that thanks to the
real gravy campaign in just 1 month
Sunday lunch Takens have doubled and the
overall turnover is up by
30% I'll start with a pro cocktail in
the scol Shell
please yeah it hasn't got mashed potato
pipe around the outside has it
yes [__]
hell so this is Brian's wow factor he
really is a stubborn old bat [__]
me [__] it I'll do it
myself nice that's what I expect to see
a prom cocktail in a
public Brian is making an incredible 250
L of gravy a week and I'm not surprised
people are flocking for this roast my
God the size of the portions
extraordinary nice
cravy nothing farted around with you I
mean
lovely
I don't think there a beef a Yorkshire
pudding anywhere in the country today
that could have matched what you served
me for lunch thank you so you know don't
piss around with it you don't need to
and whilst I'm slightly concerned that
you're back in the kitchen I hope it's
for a temporary it time only it because
if I talk to this lady in 6 month's time
God forbid
and you've popped your [__] clogs in
there on that stove I'll be [__]
furious get out of there run your Pub
not your kitchen please I will and I'm
absolutely confident that the way you
have set us up the way the menu is set
up is going to work look at me and tell
me yes would you let go yes cuz if you
do let go there's every chance this is
going to work you know
that
Brian is full of surprises he's got a
new reason to log onto his computer he's
running the campaign for real gravy
website September 342,000 hits in one
month in one month
342,000 yeah it's it's [__] fantastic
yeah 345,000 people logging on to find
out more about the F arms do me a favor
now start thinking about your next
campaign and I know what it should
be campaign for a real prawn
cocktail now you're taking the piss I'm
not taking the piss you were taking the
piss serving in a [__] scallop shell
and good luck thanks very much good
night thank you
bye [__] hell scol up shells in a
prawn cocktail [__]
hell [__] hell 30
years
this week I'm in Norfolk home of Alan
[Music]
Partridge but he's not the only one hit
wonder in
town
[__] step forward Michin star winner
Nick Anderson and as soon as you say oh
I'm the chef owner of Roco they oh W you
know it does stand for something but
Nick's stuck in the past and he's about
to lose the lot everyone's so dead stuck
in a rut and this place is going to
[__] close unless you do something
about it now he's got to say AOA and aha
to his former glories it's it's it's
trophies isn't it right now they're
going in the [__] bin they are
history bring it up I can't spell it any
clearer we are
[Music]
[__]
[Applause]
Kings Lin a traditional Market town on
the norfor coast where the order of the
day is cheap and cheerful local
crab less that is you're eating at roko
one of Kings Ling's most expensive
restaurants run by former missioning
style winner Nick
Anderson I'm very proud to when people
say you you know who are you and what do
you do and as soon as you say oh I'm the
chef owner of Roco they oh wow you know
it does stand for something or at least
it used to now roko is struggling to
survive the debts are mounting and
there's no real clear Way
Forward Nick's losing £2,000 a week and
is facing closure and if that wasn't
Tough Enough he lives above the
restaurant with his wife and two kids
they'll all be homeless if Coco goes
under my first thought is for the
boys because what would we do I mean
we'd have no we would have no money I it
just be so depressing and
miserable we used to be very very busy
and I don't think we're doing anything
differently and we're just not getting
the people it's like you know you've
organized a special party and
everybody's decided they're not going to
bother
coming I'm here in kingslin and I've got
just one week to save roko from ruin and
put Nick back in the
game well I really really really hope
he'll like Nick's food I'm reasonably
confident he's not going to sort of put
his Fork down and go that's disgusting
or minging or anything like that I I'm
fairly confident my food will will stand
the test beautiful
Church how fortunate any your rest
be next to
that Jesus looks like a [__] sofa bed
in the
window hello Hi how are you Hi how are
you very thank lawence good to see you
is Nick here he is indeed thank you this
is uh
quaint cool it's very small isn't it
hello hello hi how are you nice to meet
you likewise good to see you how are you
I'm all right warm yeah you look very
warm huh very hot boiling in here
doesn't seem very busy out there no it's
just falling away all the time you know
tonight eight people yeah on a Saturday
night customers buil how would you
describe roko roko is a full alart
restaurant yeah um what style of food is
it modern British I mean we're in the
height of Summer now so everything's
sort of well I'm about I'm about I'm I'm
about to have a menu change this is
we're just coming at the end of the
spring menu now we're going into the
summer spring we ended the F in July
spring was yeah two months ago well
right right I'll go in the dining room
I'll see you after lunch okay thank
you right go
dear
Tiny Kitchen Jesus it's like going to
visit your grand I'll read the menu
here so claustrophobic in here huge
Sofas in a little quaint
room oh [__] and may have a glass of um
orange juice please yeah pleasure ice um
is it cold with ice it will be and the
orange juice is already chilled yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying is it fridg
yeah yeah no I said thank you no I smart
ass pan roasted diver Scholars with
cauliflower puree white raisin and Caper
dressing that sounds very familiar
Nick's got one of my dishes on the menu
he's been cooking for as long as I have
and he's charging Top London prices so I
just hope his food measures
up first test a fish soup excellent and
uh
smells
off well that's certainly seen better
days I just hope I won't be saying the
same about Nick by the end of the lunch
a you
bastard so work very
well
[__] son of a
[__] next mushroom and a duck egg on
toast and it's one of my favorites when
it's done how I like it simply why is it
supposed to be looking like something
out of a [__] Barbie's doll's house
why can't it just look simple plain and
mushrooms on toast it's like eating a
wet flannel soggy horrible bread
mushrooms are
dirty Nick's obviously a Frills man but
if he's got any sense he'll serve the
next Dish as it was intended because
it's one of
mine and where did this dish originate
from I can tell you he thought the idea
you couldn't no no go and ask him for me
will you yeah sure thank
you where did you get the idea for the
scallops oh for [__]
sake thank [__] I don't serve mine like
that they taste Frozen unfortunately
milky and uh yeah rubbery they tasted
like they're frozen they are milky
try one
yeah they're not frozen fresh col Nick's
got to be joking he better put a smile
on my face with the next dish because so
far this lunch has been
miserable it's nearly there just
wondering if there's any point in
sending it to be
honest if I were you Nick I wouldn't
keep me
waiting lawence
thank you
right
cool um you like a hemid in my [__]
you know that can I just sit and enjoy
or try to enjoy rather than trying to
dissect everything I eat otherwise you
might as well [__] sit down here and
take my place would you mind no no
problem at all thank you so
much I'm nervous I say stupid things I
don't mean at least you're not having a
cut for
it that sauce is so sweet it's
unbelievable duck itself actually tastes
quite nice but then it's m with all that
horrible sauce it's almost like benlin
and baby veg 20 quid as well I mean you
know even by London prices that's you
know that's up there there's someone
here that's trying to be Flash and he
may have got away with that in the '90s
but in
2006 his days are
numbered right Nick you're not going to
like what I'm about to say I expected a
nice quick fast easy lunch and
unfortunately everything was painful you
know mushrooms on toast was supposed to
be mushrooms on toast I got something
that was incredibly soggy full of grit
and just looked horrendous the duck was
[__] delicious and then everything
else around it was so unnecessary right
you were [__] successful 10 years ago
and you had a big following MH
unfortunately nothing has moved on no
you're in the bubble and I'm about to
burst it s Laurels clearly cooking still
from the '90s era touch success but that
fizzled very very quickly even his own
customers haven't sort of hung around
long enough to tell him how [__]
long- winded the food's become so it's
yeah it's quite sad in a way and um he's
clearly not cooking for Kings Lin he's
cooking for his ego I feel slightly
deflated I didn't think I'd get as much
criticism as I got but hey I'm a big boy
I'm not a 20-year-old I'm not going to
cry I'm 40 so yeah bring it
on
this week I'm in kingsling to help Nick
Anderson a chef who once had a Michelin
star that sauce is so sweet it's
unbelievable it's almost like Benin but
after eating his food yesterday I'd say
his glory days are long gone I expected
a nice quick fast easy lunch and
unfortunately everything was
painful 4 years ago Nick was flying high
running a successful restaurant at the
crown hotel in
Wales I had a business turning over a
quar of a million pound a year got to
six out of 10 in the good food guide two
AA rosettes and a mishan star in 2001 uh
2002 2003 three years but in 2004 Nick
crashed and burned when he and his
backers parted company he's never got
over it it was very tough time leaving
Welles and um obviously very emotionally
draining we just found out Susanna was
pregnant uh obviously I then had best
part of a year on the doll um
bankruptcy and trying obviously to to
find some way of getting back Nick
opened Roco hoping to get back on his
feet but with no one coming in to eat
there he's now Heming
money this morning I want to know what
the locals have got against
roko hello how are you both thank you
have you been the rocos no I haven't no
have you heard about R I've heard about
what's the reputation in kingslin at the
moment it's quite expensive isn't it
when you look at it you think a going to
get value for money I think probably too
pricey two smaller portions I don't know
is kingslin too small for a restaurant
like
rocos they've hit the nail on the head
except for one thing it's not kingsling
that's the problem rokos has gone way
past Itself by date I mean pretentious
food stuffy service and [__]
ridiculous prices even for London
ridiculous
prices before I can drag Nick into the
real world I want to find out how he
runs his kitchen so I've arranged to
meet him and his suf Tim Sanford before
tonight's service how are you today I'm
very well nice to see you good to see
you too hello hello Chef how are you I'm
okay you Gordon Yeah Tim you're the suit
obviously the suit chef chef is it the
only Chef you ever worked for of this
caliber yes what was it like last night
dead as a doo absolutely no one no one
in at all no [__] me that's
extraordinary how do you leave the
boredom how do you stimulate yourself in
terms of coming up with new ideas it
sounds absolutely Dreadful but sometimes
I do watch Ready Steady cook and I pick
up little things from that yeah [__] me
I know it's Dreadful you're the first
chef I've ever ever met that's
becoming that's become excited and
stimulated on the back of Ready Steady
[__] um just take me through your
fridges like meat fridge where would
that be so I have my my duck my lamb
good look at the sausages they sound
nice to Lo are they actually from too
yes they are amazing this is basically
fish trimming Scarlet corals for fish
soup rice pudding mhm meline mix ni
Nick's fridges are packed with the best
ingredients but no one's coming to eat
it all is he mad you have the most
extraordinary ingredients you know that
and if you don't sell it you eat it yeah
things like you know Meat and Fish so
really it's a big Advantage the restant
being [__] empty cuz you live like a
king amazing no style food here Tim must
be [__] extraordinary it is huh yeah
well you look well on it thank you [__]
me
if Nick's in trouble he could be buying
cheaper produce on his doorstep so why
isn't he with things like the shrimps in
the freezer yeah and you're on the
you're on an EST you know 20 miles we
struggle to get them fresh we always
used to be able to get them fresh no
seriously you mustn't forget I have been
doing my homework I've been here I know
how many boats are still out fish Fleet
the I can tell you what they caught on
Saturday I can tell you what's in the
market tomorrow morning trust me okay oh
[__] me I get the feeling Nick's having
me on is in cuan everything has to look
Immaculate with the best of cheese and
the best of sausage and the best of rack
of lamb he's in kingslin yeah not sat in
the [__] Harbor of Monaco and every
customer hasn't got five grand to blow
on a [__] bottle of
wine before I tackle the business I need
to see what Tim and Nick are capable of
and so I want to watch them in action
during a busy service but things have
sunk so low at roko the only way we've
been able to fill the place tonight is
by rounding up Nick's friends and some
local business people and when you
opened 91 was the food the same then no
the duck egg with wild mushroom I
thought that was part of the history in
terms of been on the menu for a decade
wasn't from the very beginning but it
was a a dish that sort of came along
probably not yeah not long after '94
something like that so 12 years and not
years Nick's menu belongs in a museum
not a restaurant but I suppose with 12
years of practice service should be a
dodle baby veg is such a throwback to
the '90s but Nick's obviously very
attached to them okay that's finished y
[Music]
well is this slow or does it me is this
normal pace of service yeah Nick so busy
pring and preening he seems to have
forgotten the whole point of being a
chef feeding your customers sorry about
the delay
that's that's not normal for that to sit
there so long like that is it no [__]
up I forgot the black pudding and I
dropped the P pure into the uh source
for the h it [__] hard work
everything just seems so difficult so
long winded kitchen's soulless there's
no atmosphere there's no
no for someone who's earned his stripes
Nick's making a hash out of tonight's
service
[__] I just lost my [__] red wine
reduction I'm beginning to think this is
a man who's lost the plot salad's died
in the
heat like it's [__] creator
so how was that for you absolutely
horrendous is that the normal way to
work it's certainly the way that work
I'm worried because there's so much
[__] around that goes on that is so
unnecessary you're screwing yourselves
painful it's like open heart surgery
without an anesthetic it's [__]
piling crap on top of crap and using
crap on crap everything is [__] so
[__] over tweaked in a way that
you've just gone past any form of
normality with food you think that the
more I add and put in it's just going to
get better but it's not wor less is
more he slagged everything off about my
food I'm disappointed because I think he
could have at least said something along
the lines of I can clearly see you can
cook meat I can clearly see you can cook
fish he could have said something
positive to keep our morale up I do feel
choked last night I could see just how
much of a rut Nick has got himself into
sticking with the same old food has
stifled his cooking and ruined his
[Music]
business I need a way to get him
thinking about the future and not the
past I've spotted a collection of old
food guides he's been holding on to I'd
like him to let them
go who wants to come in and read the
good food guide it's it's it's trophies
isn't it because you're in there aren't
you yeah that's the kind of stuff you
have upstairs yeah for you know your
your little meditation time you know you
know when you've had a real [__] night
and you're slightly concerned and you
want to sort of you know increase the
size of your [__] you lay on the bed and
cover yourself in all your good food
guides when you get a write up in a
guide they've judged you for
what for that year the previous year yes
yeah by then you you moved on yes so
you're reminiscing right now they're
going in the [__] bin Colin I'll hold
the bag open and you can get them in
yeah I don't give a [__] how much you
pay for them you
know 15 years of History 15 years of
everything else course it sad it's
difficult sometimes to accept changes
necessary
um really
is Nick's road to recovery is just
starting he needs to embrace change but
after a decade working with the same
dishes I wonder if he can actually cook
anything
new things have got slightly static in
terms of creativity
yes come here my little [__]
rockweiler sorry [__] you mentioned to
me the other day about ready steady [__]
yeah no no no don't look at me like that
come back to with some form of
inspiration there's ingredients let's
look I've bought some basic local
ingredients and I'm giving Nick and Tim
just 20 minutes to come up with some
dishes that we can make money on onion
leaks potatoes and look at this baby
here
fresh beautiful you both got a bag each
don't copy him and you don't copy him
fine ready yeah how long steady cook how
long [__] you know how long oh this
could be the first time in years Nick's
faced a full-sized vegetable now you're
[__] sweating aren't you you seen it
on telly you sat there in front of the
[__] sofa now you're [__] doing it
okay Nick please tell me you're not
looking for a cutter where's my Cutters
where's my Cutters we Nick don't burn
your mackerel don't get Huffy with
me come on
Nick 10 seconds to go three
two one serve thank you well done
Timmy good Nick what is it just simply
grilled macro little bit thyme some
lemon juice good of macro on a bed of
saute potatoes with garlic and butter
would you serve that dish in your
restaurant I think so good would you
serve this dish in this restaurant no I
wouldn't why not cuz I think it's crap
it needs a lot of work into it you think
it's crap yeah and it needs a lot of
work doing to it yeah you feel ited yes
I did so I can cook it quicker GED it
you are so paranoid is unbelievable
presentation's there for 30 seconds it's
the flavor that holds the memory it's
the flavor that holds the memory right
Nick a
taste Ma's nice slightly bitter inside
cuz the guts are still in there
unfortunately top of the ma was nice I
like that Nick's buckled Under Pressure
Tim's held his own but they both failed
the most important test of all the leaks
and the potato I wanted a soup as my
starter and then the [__] mackerel I
wanted filleted on a [__] warm potato
salad nothing more boom boom start a
main yeah 238 I got to make money cuz I
got to [__] open my business tomorrow
okay so you do you both chose to do one
dish the winner
is none of
you clear
down [__] no
[Music]
I'm so frustrated because I can't get
anything out of [__] Nick and I got
to make some big changes in this place
otherwise uh he's
[__] it takes a little while for
things to sink in with me I'm not the
I'm not a uh really as a rule I'm not an
impulsive person I don't
act you know um without thinking things
through and I I fully suspect that
Gordon's going to get even more
frustrated frustated with me as the week
goes on but I'll probably get more
frustrated with
him it's not just nicka can't work out
if roko doesn't have any customers how
has Nick managed to keep the business
and the family of float for the past 18
months I'm going to talk to his wife
Susanna we don't go anywhere we don't
ever go out anymore since having the
children and there's nowhere to go and
we haven't got any money MH um so I
think he needs a sort of real kick or a
boost or a real something to uh get him
inspired again and I you know when it's
not busy and when it's crap like that
you he just you know he's miserable
which I suppose you would be anyone
would be yeah [__] yeah how long can you
continue staying open along these lines
not long the thing that happens is every
kind of six months Nick has a meltdown
and goes everything's [__] [__]
everything's what are we going to do
what we going to do what we going to do
we need some money we need some money if
it hadn't been literally for like a
month ago a couple of friend stroke
customers wanting to invest a little bit
of money into it can't remember how much
it was now we would it would have gone I
think if I to Clos the door tonight yeah
I mean [__] bam yeah shut down yeah
how much do I owe tomorrow morning 100
100 Grand
yeah you haven't got that no hasn't it
got it no no it's worse than I thought
even though he's in £100,000 worth of
day said Nick's still shelling out on
all the expensive produce he used when
he was doing well I need to get him to
stop he told me he couldn't buy shrimps
on his doorstep well I don't think he
tried hard
enough and one thing I got [__] off
last week with is when you said you
can't buy fresh [__] shrimps these
guys go out every day hello gentlemen
that looks like a good catch that he
told me that he can't get fresh
shrimps are they fresh from this morning
yeah and is that a normal catch in the
morning that's just average average and
you give me [__] cuz I get upset cuz
yours are in the [__] freezer hello
yeah no no I mean have a little taste
yeah sure yeah or do you want to stick
to your Frozen ones your [__] ass on
that boat let's go H unbelievable you'll
turn around and say no let me get let me
get my frozen ones yes will look how
beautiful amazing no shrim is my [__]
ass
beautiful see yeah Frozen [__]
shrimps I went to the fishmongers I told
you I went to the fishmongers another
excuse no more [__]
excuses Nick's excuses won't get him out
the financial [__] and I still don't
think he's faced the fact that his
spending habits have to change and
soon tonight I'm allow Nick to cook his
menu for the final time I'm going to do
some tough talking to try and Shake him
out of his cocoon sauces like varnish
aren't they why are they so heavy in the
middle of summer it's the only way I
know how to Sauce oh [__] hell the
only way I know how to Source I wouldn't
charge 20 for that in
Chelsea
Nicholas you noi mushrooms they look
like [__] tadp on Viagra huh is it on
there because it's Oriental the worthy
Noy yes poor bastards are you ready to
stab me yet
no
oh what's the idea behind the two
sources
resemblance of a pearl necklace I used
to give on my
exgirlfriend what lovely portion of
pork why'd you put the black buddy on
there cuz I'm over press SCH is's
anything registering in terms of all
that time we're wasting yes farting and
Fanning around I think we can fit 10
more people in and still get it done
with in the time frame I feel like
spping you start bolet naked and putting
a [__] sign on saying customer
come and eat my
food I'm [__]
serious I just can't get anything out of
him it's so hard because he's like in a
days when I poke him I poke him for a
reaction to wake him up to get him out
of that [__] aati attitude and so
every time I want to dig him in the ribs
I want someone to come back to me with
something of a pair of bollocks it's
like he's sort of putting at the back of
his mind it's not really that important
because getting all my potential
ingredients is far more important than
being 100 Grand in debt I can't spell it
any clearer we are
[Music]
[__] this week I'm in Norfolk to help
shake a chef out of his culinary coma
those sauces are like varnish aren't
they why are they so heavy in the middle
of summer it's the only way I know how s
oh [__] hell last night I tried to
get true to him with some tough love you
ready to stab me yet
no this morning I'm hoping to start
aresh Nick's in there so why isn't he
letting me
in
pathetic absolutely
pathetic kick me out who the [__] you
think he
is I've taken some [__] in my time but
this is the first time a chef has ever
locked me out of a
[Music]
restaurant I'll sit here and wait till
[__] lunchtime I'll go in as a pain
customer [__]
[Music]
[__]
what's the
matter Fed Up fed
up can we talk yeah yeah I bowled my
[__] eyes out last night Gordon we're
the same age you've got two kids
upstairs you know depending on this
[__] succeeding you know so you know
yes you're pissed off yeah you hate my
guts but let's just have a go at [__]
working at turning around don't want you
cooking like that because I think you
can do better with half the
frails you can't give
up was there nothing at all about last
night that you
saw as even remotely good if I didn't
think it was possible to turn around I
would wouldn't be
here and you wouldn't have asked my
[__] help unfortunately the reason
why you're more [__] off is the level
of sensitivity I'm glad you feel the way
you do cuz it shows that you
care well I'm certainly at the bottom
that's for
sure well at least he's talking to me
now so I'm going to strike why they are
in hot and hit him with my big idea it's
time to start from
scratch
you're going to have to seriously
consider changing the name I need a
unpretentious a name people that's like
[__] me get in there Nick any
names not yet must be something in there
just roll them out to me just Shout
Shout at me for once number 11 no cuz
there was too formal the church is
called St Margaret's I don't know
Maggie no no it's got nothing to do with
with you it's a new identity I say magg
is you know in terms of not casualness
but just unpretentious something that
everyone can relate to Nick you're
nervous of Maggie I'm not nervous I'm
just not that Keen at all yeah I'm just
trying to throw options in the
part we need a fresh start the name is
not critical the change is crucial I
don't like the name Maggie I think to me
it just
says
Maggie's Caravan stop and get a bacon
roll here we go while Nick can steing
his own juices over the loss of six
letters of the alphabet but he's not
going to stop me tearing up his
menu anything you're worried
about well that delayed silence [__] me
I can kill you okay finally a smile I
just hope he's happy with the new
food I've swapped his expensive
ingredients for cheaper local
Alternatives so we can lower the prices
and and these simple dishes can be
prepared quickly that is just a nice
summery chilled chunky rustic yeah get B
show and there's a duck
salad pan fied mackerel and a bed of
warm potatoes one nice
FP on and a simple cheese
Soule into your oven please Nick a hot
oven 220 perfect so you love the name
magg is adore it Chef no I hate it you
hate it why do you hate it just makes me
think of somewhere that you pick up a
bacon buy at the side of the road really
yeah what's the
Alternatives Nicholas I'm beginning to
lose patience with Nick no answer time's
running out I don't know how long you
think you've got but I can't tell you
any longer here Mr Anderson we're scared
of [__] change no one wants to change
anything because it's safe safe means
we're in the [__] SC change no I'm just
trying to inject a bit of energy but
right now like I said no one's no one's
with me on this one no one's clean for
ch changes no one's Dynamic for changes
and everyone's so dead stuck in a rut
and this place is going to [__] close
unless you do something about
it when I'm pissed off more than
anything I don't feel anyone [__]
pulling on the rope quite frankly it's
not good enough to sort itself out
that's why we're in the ship so I don't
feel that surge of support that really
sort of you know bang this is all I've
got in life it's not there not so if
they haven't got it what [__] chance
have I
got can't work out why Nick won't let go
of the
past I need help from people who know
him best first St
Susanna I I can't work out whether it's
just his pride yeah or whether it's you
know saying goodbye to a Coco doing
King's ly you're not in nightsbridge he
thinks Maggie sounds cheap and he
doesn't want his food to be cheap but
we're not turning it into cheap if he's
not happy with that why does he come
back to me with it I don't care if he
calls it Frank is Maggie uncle I don't
give I don't give a toss about that no
rok's myth is feeding his ego nothing
more yeah but I swear to God I look at
that man in the eyes every morning and
there's not hundred grand of debt in
each [__] eyeball yeah that is wrong
yeah if Nick goes down he's taking
everyone with him wife kids and his
staff it's an amazing place and amazing
setting quaint [__] town hall you
know an amazing square this place should
be [__] Ram people should be queing
up to stand in a queue to come and eat
in here they got everything here that's
the way it is we got to sort it out I
see someone that is hurting for what
reason Glory Days M Star possibly
possibly got to be a reason somewhere I
would have said
that 4 years ago Nick was top of the
bill in Norfolk and he staged was the
crown hotel in
Wales but when he and his backers party
company Nick had to leave the restaurant
I don't think he's ever got over it
this is where it hurts have you been
back in
there um not for a long time no not for
a long time I brought you here to face
your
failures I had a situation once when I
had two missing stars in a restaurant
called Obi and I'd worked my [__] ass
off for these guys for five
years and
because I didn't want to go down the
direction that they were going down I
cut the [__] cord and I got out of it
and it's been the most important [__]
day of my entire [__] cooking career
you have to turn a new Leaf I've never
been back in that door and I've always
wanted to go in there and just
eat but instead I used to just walk past
yes and there's like two or three bin
bags outside the front door and you know
what it makes me feel so happy because
when I was there I used to put out 18 to
20 bin bags and that told me they're
nowhere near as busy it was it was that
moment when you think the most important
day in my entire life turning the
[__] leaf and for the short time I've
known you I don't think you've ever
turned the leaf no that was then yeah
this is
now why didn't the [__] penny drop
earlier I don't know stubbornness maybe
I don't know I've been massaging my own
ego with the
food without seeing the fact that why
are the other restaurants busy because
they're not trying to be pretentious M
you have got to start a fresh [__]
move
on it's taking me the best part of a
week but I think Nick may have finally
got the
[Music]
message it's my last day in norol
tonight we relaunched the restaurant and
there's good
news I've made a decision Gordon I'm
going to run with Maggie Maggie doesn't
mean it's a [__] greasy spoon no in
six month's time the name is irrelevant
but it's the new that's where I got to
be perfectly honest why get all precious
about it skip skip thank you
gentlemen now I need another miracle
we've got to get the people of kingslin
to give Nick's new restaurant a go I
just hope they can forgive his sins I
just want to tell you about our new
restaurant it's a replacement of our
Coco well it used to be no you haven't
you liar no you haven't it's only just
been magg today we've changed the name
we've changed the interior it's
affordable the food's great now I've got
through to Nick there's no stopping him
he's agreed to dump the intimidating
night's decor and replace it with a
simple and fresh
interior oh is it open tomorrow it's my
birthday tomorrow yes it is what time
did you like to C um tomorrow about 8:00
you got a reservation there yeah well
done God when you get going it can't
stop you you know that
huh we've only got a few hours left to
clear out the final traces of roko
before we throw open the doors at
Maggie's but something's already made it
back in from the
bin no they're not going back I'm just
going to take them upstairs you're
taking them upstairs you're going to lay
on the sofa again and cover your [__]
widget with them no no no what are you
doing with the guides oh it's history
isn't it just when I thought I was
[__] getting
somewhere have you got any
paraffin I never look at them ever is
your photo in any of them Nick no
there's never been photos
you don't need them [__]
me [__]
hell what else have you sneaked back in
nothing
nothing finally all the old fashioned
remants of a Coco have been stripped out
and in its place is maggots relaxed
informal and most important
welcoming I've created a fixed priz menu
made up of modern rustic dishes the big
pool for the locals will be the the cost
at £21 is half the price of a
Coco big night tonight um 44 booked yes
42 44 yeah yeah can we take any more
Lawrence yeah if we can do them yeah
yeah definitely if Maggie does 54 covers
tonight I'm running around that square
and the cemetery start ballet naked um
menu everybody happy with the menu three
starters three main courses and three
desserts yeah we've gone through all the
[__] you know roller coaster highly
strung highly emotional upsetting
bullying it's all gone tonight is the
night really make it work good luck
thank you all for your very hard work
this week and let's make Maggie's work
if we get through this one tonight and
he pulls it off you know I'll be a lot
happier of course I'll be a lot happier
My worry is in the kitchen not with Tim
but with Nick if he gets in the [__]
early on let's hope he's got the
Charisma the personality the drive the
determination to get out of it this is
not just a man's starting off aresh this
is a man that is desperately in the [__]
up to his eyeballs with 100 Grand of
debt and [__] me every plate he cooks he
has to really seriously mean
it table in the
[Music]
window okay one crispy duck salad on
order two
gaspacho chicken mackerel
[Music]
lamb nice absolutely
stunning good too sou late they're very
hot Lawrence please be careful
yes excellent start is gone within 7
Minutes
fantastic Magus is filling up with the
locals there'll be more people in
tonight than Nick would usually have in
all week how long you duct him where did
he win you up okay duck down yeah good
nice see play thank you that's fine
that's don't play with it don't play
with it despite the fact that we got rid
of Nick's fancy ingredients he's still
fiddling he can't can't afford to switch
up
tonight what those little burn bits and
the potato
they come on come on come on come on
Nick get Tim to put the peas and there
and don't keep on sashing down so
much here calm down slow down guys and
work as a team like we sort of almost in
love with each other there you go the
new menu is doing the trick the pace is
picked up in the kitchen but it's
getting busy and now Nick has taking his
eye off the orders that guys table two
is already gone thank you what' you mean
where's that ticket please temp what is
going
on thank you that's what I want what is
going on what's going this never
happens Nick stop my man yeah we're
doing the same course again twice over
all right the next order is a chicken
and a
Acro come on come on guys not tonight of
all not tonight yeah I didn't I didn't
know you had a Lem on there I thought it
was a chicken and a
mackerel chicken and a mackerel
take
take take that one with
you Nick's just screwed himself they've
just started to cook one table's order
twice over brilliant it doesn't need to
be as panicky as it is Fu me this is
home cooking big deep breath and just
compose yourself and be comfortable
doing three or four things at the same
time and bring it together the r is now
at his busiest so if Nick doesn't take
control now we're in trouble our
bollocks is sinking we need two duck now
move it come on service please we got
three supls out yeah denying do two Su
three duck yeah two Su
three right we go seven chicken two lamb
yeah yes
sir and you got your sides on the go yes
you got your side orders on the
go car finally for the first time this
week I'm beginning to see Nick might
just have what it takes to run his
restaurant
sup 20 seconds 30 seconds placing the
chicken Tim are you ready with that soup
nearly
Chef finished with the duck we through
the worst all the Ming he served and I
think Nick's even enjoyed
himself just there you know that Nick
just so Nick's had a good night but are
we back in favor with the locals I think
the prices are right for for you to come
and have a a meal on on a regular basis
rather than just a special occasion
which it used to be definitely come
again definitely
definitely Nick's got the stamp of
approval making a fresh start has worked
so if Nick wants to bask in the Dory
again he'd better stick to the new
regime how' you feel
good good truthfully yes truthfully yeah
we just taken about 2 and a half Grand
go to a shaky start can you do it again
tomorrow that's the big question yes you
can yeah good I'm glad to hear it I
can't do anymore and it's over to you
now
yeah this is just the beginning and it's
going to go forward and it's going to
evolve and it's going to get better and
better and better um and it's just that
it will never
be it'll never be what it was because
clearly there weren't enough people
coming for what it was so it needs to be
different and watch this space tonight's
service was a tough one tough but we got
there can they cope on the back of that
performance tonight it's going to be
very tough for them to cope very very
tough indeed because they're going to
have to wake up in terms of that's
normal I'm nervous about this one more
than any other R I've ever worked in
because I don't feel that surge of
excitement to get it
[Music]
right Mr we're scared of [__] change
no one wants to change last time I was
in kingslin I spent the week trying to
convince Nick Anderson that his Glory
Days were long gone go and argue with me
come back to me by the end of the week
we'd not just changed the food we'd
launched a brand new restaurant
Maggie skip skip thank you
gentlemen 7 weeks later I'm back in
Kingsland to make an unexpected
visit nice whole roasted lemon so local
with [__]
butter hello how are you Jesus wow the
first change is obvious Nick's customers
nice bus very nice
bus good evening good evening how are
you very well good to see you good
evening Chef how are you very well thank
you Timmy how are you smashing smashing
good man thank you one me oh dear hey
you have got your [__] together uh
seriously U turn over um we're we're
averaging 4 and a half to 5 grand a week
top week's been eight top week's been
eight yeah that's great one big question
have you got a spare table of one
anywhere yep thank [__] for that I'm not
going all this way I'm not
eating the first thing struck me when I
walked in here you know it was the buzz
place is full 47 KS on a Wednesday
night kingsling is empty you know this
must be the busiest place within
[Music]
mils the exciting thing about the menu
is everything's Source locally which is
nice um if it tastes as good as it reads
then it's down to him he can't [__] this
one I'll go for the um whole soul the
Sal please with a cocko butter um and
just maybe before I start can I try a
onion B I'm trying to figure out what
the [__] they're doing here where did
that one come from Timmy I think
suggested it Timmy the cat Timmy the cat
so far so good but I'm reserving
judgment until after I've
eaten not the kind of thing you expect
to find on the menu here however it's
[__] delicious so who am I to
complain there is nothing potential
about what's being put on the plate here
and the minute the food arrives you
don't think about some potential Chef in
the corner trying to massage his ego
it's good honest simple food that's all
it has to be it's not [__] rocket
science thank
you lovely and that's local you haven't
even asked me how my dinner is yet
wouldn't even dream it not you finished
I'll let you start
[__] Jesus fish cockled butter
parsley sauteed local seeps and SED
potatoes rustic simple and so
unpretentious is
extraordinary
and miles in front to what I experienced
last time around
here that was nice Nick very nice simple
honest and uh great flavors for you
what's changed in terms of I've got it
I've got it back in here have you though
yeah really is it is it in there yeah
this is the first time I've can quite
honestly say and I mean really [__]
honestly you're cooking for your
customers not your ego it's only going
to be a matter of time before you're
financially [__] stable that there
already seriously Batman's paid right up
to date all the supplies are back within
30 days and all the wine supplies are
paid up up scratch Timmy the BG was
delicious by the way good can I have the
recipe please no you tin little [__] I
[__] I I've given you my recipes
you've had a personality transplant
haven't you where did you get this from
a lot more chefs I'd like to give it to
tell me where the shop is and I'll send
the [__] to it all JS apart don't
[__] change no I won and don't put
your [__] ego in front of your custom
I'll show menu I'll show you the menu
tomorrow don't put your [__] ego in
front of your customers your success is
the buzz in that dying room the minute
that buzz is gone you're [__] keep it
there definitely yes y well done thank
you I really mean that stubborn [__]
but well
done yeah I'm amazed what a [__]
turnaround extraordinary good honest
simple food local prod produce great
service no bits of [__] with olive
oil and all potential crap everywhere no
[__] flea bitten sofus out there no
canip is just a really good evening nice
buzz and I really hope he [__] makes
it he's got a recipe for Success here
and um he'd be stupid to change it
pretty
good
[Music]
Maggie's
done how many women does it take to run
a restaurant
badly three if it's called
Morgan's you better watch out because uh
we're going to get him I'm grappling
with G power to save this restaurant you
with us it's going to be handbags at dwn
with Mom don't tell me to shut up G I
won't be spoken to like that all right
and sibling rivalry is driving me
demented you tell these two to do my
role and death I'm sorry I
[Music]
typical Liverpool a city that's shedding
its rundown reputation
with rocketing house prices and3 billion
worth of investment it's rapidly
becoming hip and
[Music]
trendy 18th century Walton Village is
one of the city's most affluent and
exclusive
suburbs this is a typical sort of
footballers wives hangout there must be
a great catchman for ladies who lunch
especially all these amazing
[Music]
houses at Walton's heart lies
Morgans 3 years ago Andy Morgan was an
antique dealer before she changed her
shop into her restaurant the idea
actually started we actually having
dinner one night and I just said well us
to cook for friends he now tend into a
restaurant and thought great why
not Sandy runs it with her two daughters
Helen and
Laura we've pulled together fought
together we've laugh together cried
together every emotion you can ever
imagine how we're all still talking to
each other I don't know with no
customers and £100,000 worth of debt the
women will lose everything in 6 months
sisters are definitely doing it for
themselves maybe that's why we need a
bit of a testosterone from
Gordon thank you thank
you from the outside looks very romantic
perfect High Street local
eery let's get some
dinner my name is Helen Helen how are
you Don nice to meet you loveely to meet
youwise this and this is I'm Sandy Sandy
please to meet you I'm the mommy what a
beautiful place thank you and this is
this is LA La Laura how are you I'm fine
this is nicec it's beautiful do you like
it these girls serve here as well
everything all good all around is G
every single male in Liverpool should
been here today how many's books there's
a table at two at half six it's weird I
mean we're in September it's a sort of
Indian summer evening out there and
you've got two booked yeah that's it it
needs a lot of tweaking who's running
the business wielding there's three of
us three of us taking responsibility for
maybe one job yeah three managers sounds
like too many chiefs to me I better eat
yes
right beautiful little smart restaurant
very romantic and everything's slightly
uh weird apricots in a cream mashed
potato with Linker sausage vanilla and
Whiskey sauce with a fillet of beef this
isn't the sort of menu that ladies who
lunch want even I don't know what kind
of menu this is the food is French
English alak cart we sort of Bring In
tha influence you know
um Spanish it's English alart really on
one plate sometimes you can get two or
three different
nationalities Phil is Morgan's cocky but
in experienced head
chef got to be confident in your own
ability Haven it otherwise put be being
a chef I need one soup one prawns one
sausage one beef pink and one portion of
Ed fruit you bastard I need two starters
you me
thank you lovely pan fried
prawns SM
paprika they're absolutely solid I mean
really solid no thought orange segments
lemon segments in there and prawns are
just bullets hard disgusting bullets is
your and sausage C and sausage thank you
en thank you this dish is big enough for
a dinosaur it's like something out of a
Jurassic Park [__] hell
sausy on T-Rex [__] hell a cherry
tomato with a mashed potato laced with
[__] apricots that is pretty
dismal this huge dish of overpriced
stodge should be extinct no wonder the
locals aren't coming here no one's going
to sit down and and and even attempt to
eat substantial mountains of food that
doesn't make sense like that nowhere
near sticky toffee P with a butterscotch
sauuce in ice cream
Junior suf Emma is Phil's long-suffering
sidekick her star turn is sticky tofe
pudding but Phil hates it babe you know
my feelings on this [__] I know you
don't like it but day1 I've always said
it should not be on our menu trial and
error NE turn around and go what is that
what is that and he'll be told it's the
Morgan's classic sticky toffee
pudding smell
[Music]
nice
for the first time this evening I'm glad
to be here this is nice
light not too sticky the person who made
that dish doesn't put [__] apricot
and mashed potatoes together and vanilla
and
whiskey there's the verdict in
you up got a care haven't you what he
thinks I do anyway hello everyone here's
G to meet you em nice to meet you I'm
fine good to see you and you're the um
Chef to party desserts and stars and
this is Phil that's Phil Chef to Cuisine
yeah
well thanks oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
anyway it started off good I arrived and
I thought it was actually quite a
stunning intimate little place then the
food
arrived solid rockard prawns you dig
deep and you come across the mashed
potato that's got laced with [__]
apricots tomatoes and a red current je
no it's
a what the [__] were you thinking about
putting apricots inside mashed potatoes
do you know what right I actually took
the recipe from the good food magazine
the good food magazine that's the
[__] answer what were you thinking
about putting it together well why not
it's different you've got every right to
be slightly [__] off about it cuz I
would be if I cooked that
[__] and here we are in a current
situation on our ass and the chef over
there wants to [__] laugh about it
what the [__] you want me to do about it
you're standing there [__] smiling me
off [__] that you've just shown me over
the last 3 minutes your attitude stinks
it doesn't at all and you can't take
criticism can't take criticism it
there's Ways and Means are go about and
putting criticism across it's the way
you speak you speak arrogantly how would
you like to be spoken to just like a
normal person like anyone would speak to
anyone uhhuh now let's go the other way
shall we please be so kind to remove the
apricots from the mashed potato see now
you're being a [__] sarcastic no but
I don't know how I mean listen we got a
problem here yeah and there's a [__]
issue with the food now [__] Mr
chipmunk in the [__] corner is pissed
off the fact that I'm telling him
something constructive if I can't get
over that hurdle I might as well [__]
off back on the train now you understand
have have a word with a chef and he's
going to [__]
EXC if you want to talk to me talk to me
I'm talking to the own I'm a [__] kid
[__] me did you like anything about the
three coures there was one Saving Grace
yeah there was the sticky tofe pudding
was [__]
delicious oh than thank you God I just
wish I had it for my [__]
starter
foxy that's the nitty-gritty over with
anyway the not be on [__] dinner
beautiful restaurant inside great
potential then trying to [__] tell
the chef some form of constructive
criticism he's got a problem not just
with his food but with his [__]
Gob you've got every right to be
slightly [__] off about it
cuz I would be if I cook that [__]
Morgan restaurant is an oldw woman run
business trouble is it's not being run
very well and the chef over there wants
to [__] laugh about it [__] you want
me to do about take you're standing
there [__] sming me off it's serving
mountains of expensive
stge but there's a much bigger problem
the women can't decide who's in charge a
recipe for
disaster can you just try and sort our
please is a struggle sometimes and you
know we kick off and we scream at each
other and stuff do you know what's wrong
with our H just is a nightmare and I've
resigned so many times Sandy claims to
be running Morgan's but I wonder how
good a manager she really is I've
decided to look at her accounts and find
out come on right how long have you been
here uh about two years nice so where's
the office so they here that's that's
the office there yeah God how do you
manage I don't it's difficult it needs
to be bigger the Des need bloody H it's
hell cuz I can't lay anything out look
at it all jammed in there like that I
know I know s's account books are
completely hate wire where's your target
I need to do that yeah but no I just ch
no no I've got that written down I have
got that written Down's that um well
come with my hands on it right now but
can't put your hands on it right now
what have you got out of it in 3
years money financially
yeah uh well we haven't I haven't how
much have you lost in 3 years I don't
know Running a Restaurant is a full-time
job not an occasional hobby if Sandy
can't even organize the books it's
little wonder she's hired a chef whose
mouth is bigger than his talent right
Chef morning morning how are you not too
bad you yeah very than yeah yeah
slightly concerned but um a good sleep
yourself no not a good k at all damn why
cuz of last night uh-huh well that was
last night this is today that's a good
attitude today's another day M we live
in land how even cooking Phil's got more
confidence than ability he's never had
any formal training but Sandy makes his
job tougher because she won't pay him
for Preparation time the menu right it's
just basically being thrown together I'm
not allowed to come in at 9:00 in the
morning what you mean you're not allow
well Sandy doesn't want us to come in at
9:00 in the morning so how' did you get
ready for service I come in at 4:00 and
I take of throwing it together even I
can't get [__] ready from 4:00 in the
afternoon now it's starting to make
sense why you [__] so defensive
totally understand it's not entirely
your [__] fault what I want to do is
[__] work together on it no s I look
forward to it you still want to punch me
no I'll save that I'll save that till
next
week okay
good it's 2 hours before Saturday
service Morgan's only busy night of the
week with no preparation done the
kitchen's in chaos there's not even
enough food labels and just odds and
sods thrown in here what the [__] is
that [__] dog [__] so what do you
need now for service cuz the place looks
Spar if there's 30 people coming for din
it's freaking me out of it it's fre not
it's freaking me out as well carrots
broccoli beans bread PRS and is this
normal this time afternoon for you to go
off to the shops like that yeah yeah so
you don't actually get the stuff back
then for at least another hour sometimes
it don't get till
6:00 when the customers are walking
through the door [__] me
unbelievable the head chef should order
supplies but s's been buying from a
supermarket because she doesn't want to
pay Phil to do it for her before we get
any further what I wanted to say to both
of you is the [__] Supermarket is not
good enough if there question any chance
[__] surviving yeah the C [__] if
we had a dinner party at home we
wouldn't be sat here at [__] 4:00
looking for a [__] list let alone
running a [__]
restaurant beans okay French beans
vegetables I think beans beans beans oh
God no no beans hold on around the next
one beans oh good no they're they're
sliced they're prepacked [__] hell no
wa man
sorry [__] hell this way you want raw
ones good what what did we get yesterday
I think it was raw yeah yeah you sure
how many would you like
oh couple of um well Kil few pounds all
of those and and some more if you have
have you got some more than than what's
out this is ridiculous you know
[Music]
that s's panicked buying Philip steak
but she she should have had it delivered
from a cheaper
wholesaler Sandy it's [__] 5 5
where's the Phil
State well it's here somewhere no
sine
s they must know where coming no that's
never happened before that they've got
new FS rum steak rum steak
no how much is that please 53.89 389 if
we had to buy this produce on last
night's Takin we would be 30 quid
[__] sh I've got a [__] headache
let's go thank you than
byebye it's 7:00 and the restaurant is
filling
up Morgan's is a stunning beautiful
[__] restaurant unfortunately the
food is [__] the chef's way
inexperienced he's self-taught and he's
cooking with [__] expensive
ingredients bought from the local
supermarkets and Sandy is just another
prime example of an individual that's
open a restaurant without having a clue
how to run
one tonight I'm going to be watching
Phil closely Che on Chef one beef on it
one Chen more well medium please Phil's
menu is poorly designed but can he
actually
cook just what your cooking yeah
standards now yeah are you happy with
that no no no noral you're a chef hey
not off [__] Coleman no no
no feels just plain careless and it
won't put up with it watch that chicken
is burning
[Music]
again that pan have we got any
ble [__]
H kitchen started to act like [__]
slobs and happy to cook charcoal and
then send it that's not good [__]
ridiculous
tell you what he's [__] sharp in me
it's how he's got where he is isn't he
his eyes are [__]
everywhere A customer has sent back a
Creme
Brule it's like [__] baby vomit do
you know why it goes like that I think
quick W too far no no no under the girl
F don't eat that unless you prepar to
die Phils big as problem is that he just
doesn't concentrate he's simply out of
his depth making silly mistakes I just
feel as if I'm just not in control at
all of my own [__] my own job it's
[__] Doty Sandy supposed to be in charge
of this mess s what are you doing just
helping them out a
bit it's not a lot on tonight we've got
no dis a bit of a l you're helping out
the washer offer yeah well you know s's
interfering everywhere doing everyone
else's job and achieving nothing 2
seconds are you lost are you you
wondering what to do got I'm I'm trying
to do a little bit of everything keep it
on do I know that you are what is your
role tonight what what what exactly are
you doing well I've been waiting
on waiting on what tables tables okay
now you're
doing have you seen the size of that
[__] he's more capable of washing and
dying [__] PL I'm not going to I'm
not going to do it all night welcome to
the [__] lunatic
asylum s's so busy doing the dishes that
she forgot her customer's order for
gravy
he's been waiting 15 minutes and
complains to Helen so they' cleared
three main courses from that table and
one guy sat there with his sausage yeah
looking for some [__] sauce why is no
one being straight with you telling you
what they need what do they want excuse
me it's just gra St making it St making
it yeah he's waiting there food's going
cway is waiting they've cleared the
[__] plates they've cleared three
plates but it's only for one it say only
for one G he's quite happy to wait
you've got to stop kidding yourself he's
not quite happy to wait
have cleared their main
coret there's like a [__]
kindergarten here you know that kitchen
life no is it f catering life nothing
like it no this is shambolic not
catering at all fat me how long for the
gravy for um at least 5 minutes at least
minutes [__] mate catering my [__]
ass I asked for a uh some kind of SCE
sort of gravy which came took a while to
come uh to be fair 15 minutes there
thereabouts and I paid 15
quid At Last I understand what I'm
facing the chef's slip shot
concentration is producing terrible
food but he was hired by Sandy and she's
the real problem and am a restaurant her
messing in a business she knows nothing
about it's depressing to watch the
restaurant sink this
low that's the saddest main cause I've
ever seen in my entire
life so 39 years of age and seeing
that don't take it
[Music]
personally I want to know if anyone is
going to take responsibility for
tonight's
catastrophe what did you experience out
there tonight in general
um a lot of people were quite happy out
there to be honest with you you know I
I've had no complaints all night what
fascinates me about you is you're either
totally [__] oblivious to what's
going on in your own establishment or
you're [__] living a nightmare inside
your your your mind you cannot see
what's going on I can't see what's going
on Gordon I'm not stupid I'm not stupid
I can't see what's going on but I can't
deal with all these things on my own
I've been trying to keep this float for
3 years by doing a little bit of
everything but thank you okay Helen he's
diabolical whole thing is just a sh
thank you and you know what you're the
most [__] honest person in here you
know that and the more honest you're
going to be okay the more Chan this PA
has got a [__] survival good night
good night thanks good
[Music]
50% of British restaurants close down
within 3 years often because their naive
owners know nothing about the business
Sandy and her daughters can't decide
who's in charge their sibling rivalry
simmering away Helen and Laura are both
desperate to control the restaurant but
from what I've seen only one sister
stands out there's certain issues with
family and a sister wants to do it and I
want to do it and we're at the moment
sharing it between each other and I
think what we need is a kick up the
backside and we all need to realize that
you know this is it and we need to put
one person to control it yeah are you
capable of running this place you
personally yeah I am capable of running
it I think I'm the Practical one in the
family I'm a bit more grounded than the
other two they're fantastic but very
similar and a bit Airy fairy we are in
the [__] are we not yeah definitely
that's the reason why I need to open
things up yeah everything come out
identify the issues and and and start
tackling
them to save the restaurant there's got
to be a radical management shakeup so
today I'm going to be Cru to be kind all
I saw last night was just individuals
running around like headless chickens
acting like children hence the reason
why we're in a [__]
playground right what's your
role General manager front of house
bollocks no chance no chance this is
this is serious now you sadly whether
you like it or not okay are not capable
of becoming a general manager in that
establishment we've got far too many
chiefs yeah I agree insufficient Indian
you need to delegate to all the people
and tell them what she can't do it she
goes and washes up for 15 minutes to
make sure the kitchen p is there next
week and she she need to delegate jobs
so I agree with you make sure that what
she's doing is a restaurant manager job
yeah your job the house it's who I want
to be you're the
host meeting and greeting and sitting
people down yes yeah happy with that
your position is the assistant
manager who's the manager then don't get
defensive can I just do one at a time
yes yeah no one's leading unless we got
Define ex I'm sorry to interrupt you
there Gordon I was away last night and
if I had have been there things maybe
would have been slightly different but
the whole shoulders of the restaurant
wait on you know you coming in you
wouldn't have changed anything last
night cuz it was just dire it was
shambolic sweetheart and it was best
with your interest not to be there last
night excuse
me one thing you've got is balls you
know that I like the way that you
[__] blatantly know what the problems
are but you've got to get it off your
chest you know that and what are you
scared about being a manager
confrontation no it's not so much that
it's actually being given sole
responsibility cuz at the moment
sister's just walked off there cuz she's
obvious LA are you going to come in or
yeah thank
you maybe you can prove yourself you
know it's fair this is not a discussion
to separate you two or to argue among
you two okay but unfortunately one 2
three are doing all the same job sorry
you've got it completely wrong let me
just finish what I'm trying to say and
once we've all defined our roles then we
can put it into the pot yeah and clearly
you're upset yeah I am clearly upset and
that is a stinky attitude and how can
you walk away like a child I'm the one
who's run the business on my own when
these two were on holiday together you
tell these two to do my role and you can
stick back I'm sorry I typical typical
where we we decid typical she worked so
hard God you don't know all he's trying
to do is to I know we haven't been here
are you running away come over come over
don't know Laur grow up calm down can't
do what about the big sister here you're
not even listening she's fantastic but
when she runs out I have to pick the
[__] off Cal down back in the morning
calm down Laura it's completely stupid
walking off let her walk off let her
walk
off what's your
role general manager at front of house
bollocks no chance Morgan's Restaurant
was being run like a lady's lunch Club
until I made Helen general manager one
thing you've got is balls you know that
her sister Laura didn't like it one bit
you tell at least you can do my role and
you can s back on I'm sorry I down
typical well that's tough they either
change or go bankrupt Morgans can only
Survive by attracting local people
before I redesign the menu I'll have to
find out what they really want what do
you look for when you go out to your
local eery um something quick um tasty
simple have you heard of Morgans yes and
feedback too good I'm afraid what would
you look for in your local restaurant to
be treated nice by the staff uhuh and to
be treated as an individual good and how
much would you expect to pay for dinner
what would you be happy with eyes don't
pay Bo friends will
pay Morgan's menu belongs in a bad
expensive gastro pub my plan is to
modernize it with fresh ingredients and
lower the
prices we stripped It Back to Basics and
homed in on good local honest produce
and kept it very very simple something
light vibrant a salmon for instance
poaching a really nice ainal broth but
it doesn't get any better than
[Music]
that I'm going to buy one item here
something simple something
local Morgan's middleclass neighborhood
is full of Foodies they love fresh tasty
ingredients served up in healthy
attractive dishes incredibly Sandy and
Phil haven't realized this even though
there's a great Organic Market on their
doorstep I'm s Sandy nice to meet you
slightly Dotty guess what where you get
some meat from uh orious on a
supermarket it is a supermarket yeah
that's right however that's stopped now
and we're going to look for some lamb
steak something simple something local
and something not too expensive okay
this is excellent locally produced lamb
just gives a little bit of excitement
from The Waitresses to sort of eight
this is local organic lamb B we got it
from the farmers market this morning in
our street and just starts to make it
feel a little bit more [__] romantic
thank you excited about 306 we don't do
Tesco Clum points so call it
50 okay lamp staks yes yeah little bit
Ro me little bit of garlic bonees gone
Phil's a selftaught chef who knows very
little so I'll have to start from
scratch with him what you've got to do
is just remember you're stepping up to
the challenge huh big time this lamb
steak is my first dish designed for
Morgan's traditional
menu get some color on there not quite
we'll serve it for for Sunday lunch
tomorrow and then finally yeah
gravy lamb sauce over the top now if
anyone complains paying 1250 for a lamb
steak it's clean it's local it's fresh
that for me ooes value for
money it's just about going back to
basics very simple dish tasty easy to
do just want want me to succeed
[Music]
like Sunday isn't a day of rest in the
restaurant business there's lots of
money to be made incredibly Morgan's was
closed on Sundays but to test my new
team and my new menu I've decided to
open for
lunch it's Helen's day off so sensitive
as assistant manager Laura is in charge
Laura or supposed to
be where in the [__] is
everyone today was a big chance to
impress me she said she's got a business
degree
Lauren so who's running it today none of
the managers in none of our So-Cal I'm
not sure where the Laur is in today so
who's leading it today who's running the
[__] restaurant
today basically Laura on her own
probably will she be in
it's a [__] joke what's worse it's
Laura's responsibility to sort out the
reservations where's the table plan for
today Laur must have it we're just the
chefs my host Sandy hasn't turned up
either [__] plot thickens she's
having pains in her chest last night so
this place needs a person to come in the
morning open up and [__] spy everyone
check on the kitchen work with the
kitchen table plan and give some umph
but it's like a it's like a free house
here you know
that it's 12:45 and Laura's still not
here you reach Laura's if you like to
leave me a message I'll come hi Laura
and good afternoon it's Gordon I'm in
the resturant I can't believe I'm
chasing the management to come into to
work in their own restaurant on such a
crucial
day I've been told s's at home
resting
Sandy
Sandy was you won't even
[Music]
answer oh [__]
hell Sunday Bloody
Sunday if you're not prepared to face up
the responsibilities of running a
[__] business then why open it in the
first place pathetic [__]
pathetic
morning Laura finally turns up but no
apology
[Music]
to cap it all she can't even find her
own table plan has anybody seen the page
up box no the first customers are due in
20 minutes 2 hours ago we were in the
same you know situation that's what I
said are we looking for it sorry now she
just being rude Laura Laura come here
minute come heree come here really is is
this because things ran quite smoothly
last night so it's like a ploy to sort
of mess things up I'll run the [__]
show if you don't show me some form of
[__] business study degree that
you've been [__] Haring on you've got
I just can't well stop being so [__]
stupid now you're blaming me for the
[__] reservation book 2 hours ago
when you were in bed we're in here
looking for the [__] thing it's gone
can we move on and try to get some form
of shape in this restaurant okay isn't
that the most sensible thing to do but
let me just tell you what I've witnessed
in the last 3 hours here hello you can
shake your head and run off again this
time I don't give a [__] but don't dare
blame me for this chaotic mess you don't
have to be in group Lord come here a
minute I'm just going to get oh not
again not again not again
bollocks
unbelievable by Helen I'm desperate for
a real manager I'm just concerned Helen
you know that I'm just like [__]
staff have gone the two in the kitchen
okay thank you bye-bye
bye Helen's on her way in but I have to
run it until she gets here Emma you
serve the starters come around and jump
on the main coures yeah how are you
welcome good
see now we're up against it a birthday
party for 12 have turned up unannounced
clear your space clear area so you've
got a nice clean yeah area to think and
[__] work with yeah welcome good to
see you it's been a bit of a manic
morning for Sunday just face the music
and dance at least someone's happy but
what we're about to receive may the
great architect of the universe make us
truly thankful amen with filling the
kitchen they might well need the
almighty's help I hope to God he
remembers what I've taught
[Music]
him now I'm reduced to waiting on tables
it's how I started out the birthday man
himself thank you you're allowed a
second portion and the third vegetable
sou what's wrong talk to me I forgot to
put the saw so come on come on than
concentrate concentrate come on what I
need in here hey is for you to stay on
top of it you know that yeah yeah before
you start sending that main course in
your mind have a little rehearsal lamb
cabbage potato carrot sauce just run it
through and the more you test your mind
you can't
forget the Cavalry has arrived at last
Helen am I happy to see you what I'm
more pissed with anything is just the
most amazing [__] potential lunch
fully booked waiting L for lunch and
[__] yeah a golden opportunity going
down the drain yeah however you're here
yeah stabilize the ship thank you for
all your
[Music]
help come on Phil don't forget what's in
the oven no yeah and start organizing
how to start dressing nine main courses
with Emma Emma yes Che need Che Place
need more Phil's concentration deserts
him and he's making charcoal again de
bad at least one Chef here has high
standards Phils two Chef Emma turns out
to be a dark horse she's quick diligent
and passionate her talents go beyond
sticky tofe pudding Phil can't cope
without her it's like home cooking isn't
it it's like this has really kicked
everything into touch now it's
beautiful it means a world to me to stay
busy on a Sunday cuz it just wasn't and
that's why I'm here now so that things
go well we take a lot of money and
they'll be all back next Sunday I was
right to put Helen in charge we've just
about got away with
it but with Sandy ignoring me and
Laura's strops it's not good enough you
got to understand I'm feeling sick I
arrived here this morning and it was
pandemonium so whilst I totally respect
you weren't feeling well I could still
do with your support you have my support
we're drawing a line today and we're
moving forward it's not a lifestyle it's
a business and we're going to treat it
like a
business I want you to let your Chef do
his job and if he doesn't do that job
get rid of him really sorry but if you
don't [__] act and cook and run this
place like a chef and don't expect to be
[Music]
here I've been really struggling with
how to relaunch this shambolic
restaurant but I've had an idea to
invite some local celebrities and create
a stir around here is listed with Wags
actresses and actors uh Hol Oaks is
filmed around the corner and it's a
perfect opportunity to get some really
good publicity for the restaurant so
it's neighborhood and the minute anyone
spots anyone famous in there they all
want to descend upon it so that creates
a buzz
it's a Race Against Time for Phil he's
got to master some classic and healthy
recipes to lure those ladies who lunch
taste tell me what that
needs salt yeah good Emma's the best
thing in the kitchen with her helping
Phil we may succeed with the relaunch
you are the second
Chef there's no reason why not you can't
run this place down the line in his day
off you know that you're
moreable I really mean that and if you
can be that passionate about a sticky
tofe pudding [__] knows what you're
going to be like when you're let loose
on [__] meat or fish
huh for the relaunch I thought of a new
role for Sandy to stop a meddling why
don't we for the first time ever in
between courses start auctioning off
some of these items oh wow I'm very
impressed with them yeah selling
antiques is what she's good at and
there's plenty around to keep her
occupied just in between courses
really we can start moving some
stuff the great thing is of all he's
actually defined everyone's role and
that's it now we're all going to stick
to it and life should be a lot
[Music]
better we fully booked for the relaunch
today and I'm
nervous I've sted my reputation on
[Music]
Morgans key to my strategy is ability to
cook my new menu but I'm still not
convinced about him all right Chicken in
skin side down first olive oil Why Not
Butter put on the he has to concentrate
on getting the basics right you just
slow down for me and [__] think a
little bit harder we [__] 90% of the
way there you know that yeah yeah do not
get
distracted excellent morning morning how
are you f nice come through come through
on come through all right let me put
these now just going through two or
three dishes chicken with the lentils
and the poach salmon in an Autumn broth
mhm and nice crispy
skin tasty very tasty you have got to
realize the potential here 48 book for
tonight normal restaurants are
struggling to get [__] five in let go
through it's time for a pep talk and my
ragtag team needs some help even from
sensitive
flowers Laura has finished sulking and
has decided to lend a
hand Laura welcome back thank you
concerned about assistant manager
manager or just concerned about running
the place just concerned that the place
is running smoothly good I've still
expected him to Roar but for now hello
I'm quite happy I'm quite stable he
unsettles
[Laughter]
me
[__] big night tonight yeah it's
could be something quite major don't
[__] it when the [__] hits the fan we
stay United we've all got our jobs to do
with no
interference no interference I'm very
happy I'm very happy to take a bux the
celebrities have taken the bait first in
are Holly Oak Stars Sarah dun and
Jennifer
bidd the footballer wives have come too
including Louise Owen Michael's wife
and next in is Sher
Murphy where Wags hang out others will
surely follow my strategy is paid off
good to see you hungry yes going to eat
dessert as well yeah there no skinny
minis here are they got proper proper
proper Foodies okay who doesn't need to
be behind the bar there's no one on the
floor there's five people behind the bar
Helen's cracking the Whip and keeping
Sandy and the waitresses in
line the new menu is going down well can
I get the roast chicken bre
table set fre chicken but Phil has a
problem Laura an order she taken you
took it on table s and there's no check
in the kitchen nothing on the top there
an order has gone missing and the
customers are waiting they been waiting
20 minutes and you go and sort it out
please did you get a table six in no no
come on
guyson for me and chicken and that start
us out straight away please them yeah
it's not your fault yeah one had it one
salmon one chicken one lamb please Phil
you try and push that table forward [__]
now I'm night like tonight Joy thank
[__] the kitchen solid that's all I'm
saying oh God two rotos yes yes good man
don't drop yeah no we'll fill keep's
concentration and cook my menu well
enough to impress Walton's glitterati
this is do more [__] nothing it's
very hard to
keep despite the [__] up everyone seems
happy I just hope the customers want to
bid for s's
[Applause]
antiques Sandy may be clueless about
running restaurants but when it comes to
selling antiques she's a natural Mr R
what are we going to start at D house £
but somebody will me
202 is
20 any advance
on50
one
70 over there 8090 00 that's your
[Music]
bid dirty Chef's a Happy Chef like a pig
and [__] let's go we have table 10 45
thank we're selling at45 now I'll get it
I'll get it oh 50 just in
time50 50 the local celebrities are
flashing their cash but what do they
think of the food it's very
nice it's delicious actually cuz it's a
bit crispy but it's also very tender as
well it's lovely really really nice I'm
really impressed I definitely come back
again it's been somewhere that I've
never actually come along to cuz I've
heard good and bad things about it but
um yeah definitely come back Phil's
cooked his heart out and not burnt a
thing a feel more than
Sal as he says as he just [__]
knocked the salsa over [__] now what
a [__] Emma's played a vital role too
I'm just think it's gone well today it's
it's been a pleasure to work today
actually selling at
£65 Morgans is transformed just a week
ago it was in chaos under Doty Sandy
serving up tasteless stodge from a
supermarket £140 thank you very much
indeed good huh that's what I do what
you on your element for God sake I've
never seen you so [__] happy how how
much did you take and [__] selling
the Antiques what did we sell 5600 5600
fantastic sorry in 15 minutes that's
[__] good news [__]
hell tonight you found your role don't
take that the wrong way but that's what
you're good at doing I agree with you
and you have been the toughest nut I've
ever attempted to crack yeah yeah okay
dining room I just want you two to to
combine no one's in competition with
each other you know you both have an
amazing [__] role yeah the kitchen
solid I cannot tell you the difference
from tonight in comparison to what went
on 7 days ago is extraordinary and the
minute you start changing it and
reverting back to the old
ways you're
[Music]
[__] I'm back in Liverpool it's a
month after I turned failing beastro
Morgans into a packed Neighborhood
Restaurant but there's been a shocking
development Helen's told me that
following her R she's let someone
go um I'm on the search for Phil um he's
left Morgan's and uh you he set up camp
here so uh time to get a hold of him
find out what the [__] going on really
Jesus what the [__] are you doing here
how are every you how are you yeah good
to see you feeling s you looking well I
feel well what happened she said that
she had loads of complaints so my
services were not required no more
there's not a lot I can do about it now
so I've moved on and I end up putting me
Mark on here some without me there
Phil's concentration went again but it's
actually good news now as a sue Chef
he'll train under an experienced head
chef SL to stay focused do what I'm
supposed to do listen and concentrate
more on my job just feel less last do
you want to take that please it's for
the best that Phill has left Morgan and
I'm pleased for
him I'm off to the restaurant to find
out the owner's side of the story I'm
worried about what's happened to my menu
and just who's cooking
it slightly nervous because it was a
month ago [__] hard work and I came
across an owner that was totally
clueless when it came to running a
business
ladies hello how are you you well good
to see you you well hello yes nice to
see you how are you got that color back
on your cheeks again yeah how are you D
welcome back you've been you've been in
the hairdresser oh yes course you
looking Immaculate as ever thank you
very so who's in the kitchen Emma's
still here Em's now our head
chef that's fantastic news my biggest
worry about Phil was the level of his
concentration we had to let him go we
thought that you know where we want to
be and Emma was the next step and she's
been there for us and dedicated and 100%
we've had promise
so hello so Emma the Dark Horse of the
kitchen has been rewarded for all her
hard work have you taken the ring yeah
I've tried to I'm getting more
confidence I remember you saying to me
come out your corner you're like a
little mouse and everyone said to me oh
Emma's got very authorative in the
kitchen I'm pleased I'm so pleased that
means the whole place has been by
females by females which is working
[__] well what I'm dying to eat I
can't believe how quiet this is the beef
looks fantastic out there with a clerc
mash brazed beef yeah and brazed with
apricots definitely
not that sauce now head chefs are
predominantly male and it's just good
that I I'm having a go and someone's
given me the chance to have a go and Stu
to me approve myself now so last week we
took just under £4,000 yeah Helen's
computerized the accounts
a big contrast to s's chaos week before
I came here you barely hit ,500 we we
lose and then we broke even and now
we're in profit and we have done for
three weeks we've been in profit you
seem a lot more confident than you did a
month ago yeah in terms of your role
defined i' well people have sort of had
confidence in me which is the you know
the first thing about you can portray
what you want to do and put your foot
down and people don't listen to you but
once you've been given a Define role and
people start believing in you then yeah
yeah gives you power and wings to want
to fly and do what what you're
doing it's great to see the restaurant
full and Emma is so tuned into the menu
that she's even added a dish of her own
braed beef thank you nice lovely
py look how tender that beef is he's
just falling apart almost like it's
melting on your
fork
[Music]
wow
that's
delicious [__] H it's so upsetting
you know that in comparison to dinner I
had last time I was here I just canot
compare this is
delicious food was delicious really good
absolutely spot on I want to in press
yeah you certainly did that don't stop
yeah good night good night ladies thank
you not a man in
sight not a man in sight is just the way
we like it
no the ladies of Morgan's are now making
money against all the odds girl power
has saved this restaurant see the wi
there I'm happy Morgan's is now running
as a neighborhood restaurant Helen's in
control of the business Emma clearly
knows what the [__] she's doing in the
kitchen and she seems so much more
confident happy customers happy staff
and the food was delicious thank God for
that
Morgans it's got it right
thanks fun for
[Music]
that
for